[Musique]
bonjour mesdames messieurs ici Céline
Galipeau nous poursuivons notre émission
spéciale sur ses adieux à la reine
Elizabeth II en Grande-Bretagne et dans
le commonwalt ce matin les funérailles
de la reine ont eu lieu à l'abbaye de
Westminster une cérémonie grandiose en
présence de plus de 2000 invités le
cortège a ensuite traversé le centre de
Londres une dernière fois et vous allez
voir les images du convoi funéraire dans
environ une demi-heure la dépouille de
la reine devrait arriver au château de
Windsor c'est la plus vieille des
résidences royales il y aura ensuite une
procession à pied encore une fois
jusqu'à la chapelle Saint-Georges pour
un service religieux et le corps
d'Elisabeth II sera ensuite déposé en
privé dans la stricte intimité dans la
chapelle de la chapelle du roi George VI
au côté de son mari le prince Philippe
de son père le roi George VI et de la
reine-mère ça ainsi que sa soeur
Margaret alors nous poursuivons avec nos
invités Estelle Boutier analystes de la
monarchie rebonjour Estelle Marc
Laurendeau journaliste spécialise la
monarchie rebonjour Marc et le révérend
Bertrand Olivier acteur de la cathédrale
anglicone à Montréal rebonjour alors
c'est vraiment la dernière étape qui
s'amorce Marc
un lieu qu'elle affectionne le château
d'où Ensor qu'elle a vous vous en
rappelez peut-être réparer à ses frais
parce que quand est arrivé le fameux
incendie
contre elle pouvait pas demander à
l'État d'assumer tout ça on a pris deux
décisions celle de elle-même puisé dans
sa cassette pour restaurer le château et
commencer à payer de l'impôt aussi
c'était aspect exemplaire qui est
survenu durant l'année horrible qu'elle
a vécu et puis c'est le lieu familial
c'était dit tout à l'heure c'est là où
elle était un peu plus à la campagne
c'est combiné la ville la campagne
tandis que Boker c'est le bureau là
c'est comme être constamment à son
bureau elle aimait pas ça tandis que
Windsor en plus d'être un lieu plus
agréable pour elle c'est un lieu
historique familial puisque Georges
Cécile enterré le prince Philippe on
s'en souvient eux il s'est finira il a
des mariages aussi qui ont été
célébrésiles se sont mariés
et Camilla se sont mariés là aussi
c'était d'un point de vue religieux
d'embrayage était béni mais c'était pas
tout à fait un mariage anglican en fait
c'est pas à l'intérieur de l'église
c'est-à-dire que normalement le clergé
en Angleterre peut officier en tant que
célibataire mais en l'occurrence parce
qu'il y avait un divorce la doctrine
officielle de l'Église en décane est
toujours à l'époque était toujours
contre le mariage de divorcé en
particulier pour le monarque que vous le
futur monarque qui est le super
gouverneur de
sauf que bien sûr ça a changé mais donc
il avait effectivement eu une cérémonie
de bénédiction de son mariage mais pas
un mariage religieux qui avait quand
même étonné mais qui a quand même montré
aussi une certaine ligne à ne pas
dépasser vu ses circonstances qui
étaient particulières très particulière
on voit donc cette chapelle
Saint-Georges où auront lieu les
la cérémonie à peu près 800 invités donc
le premier ministre Trudeau il sera avec
son épouse et d'autres d'autres membres
des d'autres dirigeants des pays du
commonwears de la famille royale
également et des familles royales
européennes on peut s'attendre à ce
qu'il cueillent un certain nombre
d'entre eux qui participent à cette
cérémonie puisque en fait ils sont tous
parrains et la majorité des monarques
européen actuels sont des descendants à
3 ou 4e degré de la reine donc ils sont
des cousins des petits cousins et
ça va être certain là que on peut
s'attendre à les voir aussi à cette
cérémonie publique le meilleur exemple
de ça c'est justement Juan Carlos qui
était au funéraire lui-même est relié à
la reine Victoria et sa femme sa fille
de greffe ici il y a toujours un lien
elle a eu tellement de descendants un
moment donné sans même toucher la Russie
les monarques de Russie le tsar
c'était à l'époque des Canada et son
épouse Alexandra était tous les deux
descendants de la reine Victoria et le
TSA le Kaiser Guillaume Guillaume II de
d'Allemagne était aussi descendant de la
nuit dernière et puis évidemment le roi
qui règne en Angleterre aussi George V
qui à l'époque était aussi descendant de
la reine Victoria et
maintenant de nos jours c'est le milieu
de descendants qu'on peut compter pour
la reine Victoria donc il y en a il y en
a quelques-uns qui habitent ici au
Canada donc et c'est partout ils sont
partout dans le monde mais
le roi de Norvège sa mère c'était
une une petite fille du roi Edouard VII
ils sont tous quand on commence à
étudier cette famille là on voit tous
les liens et heureusement que d'une
génération à l'autre il ne porte pas
tous le même prénom alors parce que là
ça devient compliqué de retrait
compliqué de s'y retrouver on pourrait
dire si on voyage un peu critique qu'ils
avaient plus de liens entre eux qui n'en
avaient avec le peuple dans certains cas
au début du siècle c'est monarchie là
était moins proche du peuple moins
soucieuse de ça qu'elles le sont quelles
leçons maintenant celles qui ont survécu
mais elles avaient elles avaient comme
des affinités entre elles qui
à une époque même
à l'époque de 4 et une deux beaucoup de
cours d'Europe parlaient français il y
avait des parce que c'était une des
langues officiellement parlé il y a les
cours de Saint-Pétersbourg on parlait
français et reine Élisabeth parlait très
bien français son fils Charles également
très aimé Les Petits Princes Williams
c'est un peu plus laborieux mais on peut
s'attendre à ce qui s'y mettent mais non
lors d'un des voyages qu'il a fait
ici au Canada il avait fait il avait
parlé quelques mots en français mais on
voyait que c'était pas aussi facile que
on l'a très bien vu lorsque le prince
Charles à l'époque quand il est venu au
printemps mais le discours qu'il a fait
en français les gens s'étonnaient de
voir qu'il parlait même pas avec un
accent donc non il parle très très bien
français on voit le convoi là il devrait
arriver vers 10h06 le corbillard devrait
arriver au château de Windsor et là le
cercueil sera
transférer sur un affût de canon pour
être pour une procession qui va avoir
lieu à pied oui les gens lancent des
fleurs là aussi pour un hommage à la
reine d'ailleurs en hommage à la reine
on va voir cette photo qui a été publiée
par Buckingham Palace c'est donc la
dernière photo officielle qui a été
publiée
la voici c'est plutôt très
souriante de la reine cette photo a été
prise dans le pour dans le cadre jubilé
de platine au mois de juin dernier et on
voit très très bien
sans vous sourire évidemment c'est son
collier de perles de trois rangs de
perles ça c'est sa signature et le bijou
qu'elle porte à l'épaule c'est une
broche en Aquamarine qui lui a été
offert par son père pour ses 18 ans
alors mais c'est vraiment
le souvenir que je crois que la majorité
vont garder d'elle ce sourire cette
cette gaieté de faire
on a l'impression qu'elle veut nous
parler qu'elle va encore nous dire
quelques mots et c'est ce que les gens
lorsqu'il a rencontré lorsqu'elle
circulait parmi la foule c'est que
lorsqu'elle parlait à quelqu'un son
attention était à cette personne-là et
seulement cette personne là alors les
gens c'est pour ça que lorsqu'on est les
journalistes intervient les les gens
dans la foule il dit ceux qui ont eu la
chance de la contre de la rencontrer
c'est ce qu'il dit c'est que elle nous
parlait à nous et seulement à nous donc
les gens vont s'en souvenir longtemps de
de la Reine Elizabeth ils le disent que
c'était comme la famille on doit aller à
Londres tout de suite parce que on nous
attend James Blitz c'est un journaliste
indépendant ancien rédacteur en chef du
final Times monsieur Blitz bonjour
bonjour à vous alors je voudrais vous
demander ce que vous ressentez en cette
journée
[Musique]
des funérailles un peu plus tristes un
peu plus sombres qu'est-ce que vous
retenez donc de cet hommage incroyable
auquel on a assisté depuis son décès
mais c'était une journée remarquable
c'est une journée remarquable on a vu
toute la pompe funèbre toute la pompe de
l'État britannique en sa splendeur au
centre de tout je pense il y avait une
cérémonie à Westminster avec qui était
simple dans dans
la reine était une femme très religieuse
très ambitaine elle aussi une femme de
goût très simple alors
c'était intéressant de voir qu'il n'y
avait pas tellement de pompes autour de
ce qu'on faisait la base c'était
intéressant de sentir particulièrement
le joueur de cornemuse à la fin c'était
très émotionnel quand il jouait et on a
vu d'autres choses on a vu les
canadienne qui était au commencement de
la cortège chose qui probablement était
intéressant pour canadien mais en
général tout est allé très bien pour la
famille royale et l'hommage auquel on a
assisté au cours des jours précédents
tous ces britanniques qui sont venus lui
rendre hommage là aussi c'était dans 13
ordonné très discipliné malgré le nombre
incalculable de personnes mais ça
c'était impressionnant aussi non pour
vous
oui vous avez raison il y a eu un
opération de police inédite dans notre
pays je pense qu'il y avait 10000
officiels qui étaient aujourd'hui en
opération et en général tout va bien je
pense que la fameuse la famille royale
et les autorités britanniques sont
spécialistes dans les cérémonies de
comme ça même si celui-là est le plus
grand que nous avons vu depuis la mort
de Churchill en 65 elle était donc un
symbole extraordinaire un symbole de
stabilité de continuité mais maintenant
que la page se tourne est-ce que vous
êtes inquiet pour la suite pour l'avenir
de la monarchie
on doit être un petit peu inquiet parce
que
Elizabeth rejouait d'un très grand
respect et même si Charles est beaucoup
plus populaire aujourd'hui qu'il n'était
autour de 70% des gens disent maintenant
qu'il sera un bon roi on ne sait pas
comment les choses vont évoluer ce n'est
pas facile de voir à ce moment parce que
nous sommes au moment des obsèques et à
ce moment il y a un très grand respect
pour la famille royale etc mais
qu'est-ce qui va arriver l'année
prochaine l'année prochaine quand il y
aura l'intronisation de Charles ça sera
peut-être politiquement plus intéressant
dans le sens que s'il y a un mouvement
républicain dans ce pays on va peut-être
le voir
parce que Charles III arrive quand même
dans une période de grands ébullition
sociale en Grande-Bretagne période
économique difficile pour les Anglais
est-ce qu'il va être en mesure de
d'unifier le pays comme le faisait sa
mère
ça va être difficile pour louer vous
avez exactement raison
la reine est morte à un moment très
difficile pour notre pays sur le plan de
l'économie à nous avons un taux
d'Afrique d'inflation très ordre de 15%,
nous avons une crise d'énergie
dont tout le monde est en train de
souffrir mais c'est particulièrement
fort particulièrement forte ici cette
crise et je pense que les gens seront un
petit peu déprimés déçu dans les jours
et les semaines suivantes parce que il
trouve que leur vie est un petit à ce
moment beaucoup plus difficile qu'il
n'était et maintenant ils ont perdu
cette personne qui représentait le calme
au centre de notre vie nationale ça va
être difficile pour les gens on l'a vu
quand même Charles III à l'oeuvre là
depuis plus d'une semaine il est allé au
devant de la foule à plusieurs reprises
qu'est-ce que ça nous indique sur le
genre de monarque qu'il veut être et
quel genre de roi il va être parce que
ça c'est la grande question comme vous
dites
oui c'est une grande question tout
d'abord je suis absolument sûr qu'il ne
va pas intervenir dans les grands sujets
du jour la politique toujours de la même
façon qu'il a fait pendant il était
prince de Galles il sait très bien qu'il
ne peut pas continuer comme ça alors il
y aura un changement ce que je pense
c'est que il sera peut-être une autre
forme de monarque de souverain que la
règne la reine était quelqu'un qui
voulait
représenter
l'état qui ne voulait pas dire mon coco
mais voulait être un symbole très fort
Charles on parle de lui peut-être plus
comme un rassembleur quelqu'un qui peut
réconcilier les divergences entre les
gens et on a vu par exemple il était
allé en Écosse il était Leon en Irlande
du Nord où il y a beaucoup de problèmes
nationalistes et il a montré qu'il peut
parler avec tout le monde d'une façon
très calme très digne et ça peut être
représente quelque chose qu'il peut
faire comme moi il peut se montrer
irrité aussi non on l'a vu un peu
impatient avec les stylos qui
fonctionnait pas et tout ça
c'est vrai c'est un homme on parle Louis
d'un homme qui a toujours toute sa vie
était un petit peu trop chouchouté un
homme qui est pour qui tout est fait
très formellement il y a beaucoup de
serviteurs autour de lui et il y a eu
ces deux événements quand il a eu
quelques bagarres avec un stylo l'autre
fois avec un encré on peut peut-être
dire que c'est un homme qui est souffre
il est en deuil à ce moment et on peut
avoir un peu de sympathie pour lui mais
c'est vrai la reine on doit dire pendant
70 ans
n'a aucune fois fait une erreur pour se
voir comme ça pour se montrer un petit
peu irrité par quelque chose alors à 73
ans il doit un petit peu se contenter un
petit peu ça peut-être ça ne sera pas
facile je ne sais pas mais on le voit là
serrer des mains se rapprocher quand
même il a voulu se rapprocher
de ces sujets de son peuple depuis
quelques jours
oui exactement je pense que la chose
qu'il a fait qui est très bien et qui
était un petit peu inattendu c'est que
immédiatement après la mort de sa mère
il est tout de suite aller sur un tour
de tout le Royaume-Uni il est allé on
est quand s'il est allé en Irlande d'une
langue du Nord il est allé au Pays de
Galles il est allé en Angleterre et
c'est qu'est-ce qu'il a fait en faisant
ça c'était une bonne idée parce que ça
lui mettait immédiatement en contact
avec les gens et c'est important qu'il a
fait ça et c'était un moment où il était
en deuil alors il y avait un respect
pour lui quand personne qui a perdu sa
mère mais qui montre immédiatement qu'il
veut accomplir ses fonctions publiques
et ça crée une atmosphère de respect
autour de lui ouais parce que ça arrive
à un moment où il y a quand même des
problèmes en école on pense à un autre
référendum donc sur l'unité du pays a
quand même plusieurs questions qui se
posent
de très grands problèmes et honnêtement
ce sont des problèmes qui ne pas
contrôler le problème en Écosse
aujourd'hui et que les Écossais ils ont
fait un référendum pour l'indépendance
en 2014
ils l'ont perdu les causes est encore
dans le Royaume-Uni mais maintenant le
parti nationaliste qui est au
gouvernement veut le refaire et il y a
une probabilité qu'ils vont avoir du
succès parce que le grand problème de
notre pays c'est le brexit nous avons
quitté l'Union européenne les causes ne
voulait pas quitter il est très
urophile l'Angleterre veut continuer à
être
hors de l'Union Européenne et ça crée
une tension qui sera très difficile de
régler dans les années suivantes alors
ça sera vraiment un problème pour
Charles le parti indépendante veut après
indépendance si l'indépendance arrive
qu'il continue à être roi de l'Écosse du
même façon qu'il est à ce moment aura du
Canada mais les difficultés sont grandes
donc
est-ce que vous pensez qu'on ne risque
pas au fond maintenant même s'il demeure
a peut-être un roi de transition a
assisté à une remise en question de la
monarchie chez vous
comme j'ai dit c'est très difficile à ce
moment de juger la situation parce que
le pays est en deuil et il y a un
respect pour Elizabeth et pour la
monarchie mais il y aura beaucoup de
problèmes dans les années suivantes par
exemple qu'est-ce qui va arriver avec
l'intronisation l'année prochaine on ne
peut pas faire un intronisation
du large et grande et majestuelle comme
nous avions comme nous avons fait en
1953 et quelle sera la situation avec le
Canada l'Australie le néo-zélande
exactement Charles continue à être chef
d'État de 14 pays de Common
et je ne sais pas si on peut continuer
avec un situation où le Canada
l'Australie peuvent avoir un chef d'État
qui est à l'autre côté du monde c'est ça
qu'on veut on doit on doit examiner dans
les années suivantes et pour la
monarchie ça va être difficile
en terminant monsieur Blitz vous est-ce
que vous gardez un certain souvenir
personnel de la reine qu'est-ce que vous
allez garder
je ne l'ai jamais rencontré
personnellement la seule chose que je
peux dire et quand j'avais 11 ans en
1972 j'ai écrit une lettre à la reine le
prince Philippe pour les félicites
féliciter pour le 25 20 25e année de
mariage et j'ai reçu du backing Palace
une lettre que j'ai toujours conservé du
Lady waiting pour me remercier c'était
très très gentil
voilà c'est la seule souvenir je ne l'ai
jamais rencontré mais c'était une femme
remarquable on ne peut pas nier ça même
si monarchiste ou non c'est vrai on voit
on sent cette attachement que vous avez
que tous les Britanniques semblent avoir
tous pour pour leur reine qui qui sera
enterré bientôt à Windsor là on voit son
convoi qui arrive à Windsor monsieur
Bliss merci beaucoup c'était fort
intéressant merci d'avoir pris ces
quelques minutes pour nous parler
merci beaucoup
au revoir
alors je retrouve nos invités maintenant
pour parler beaucoup de sujets en fait
on voit à quel point cette cette
disparition de la reine peut changer
quand même beaucoup de choses en
Grande-Bretagne on se questionne sur
l'avenir ce qui va arriver comme il
disait Charles III va être intronisée
l'année prochaine mais on sait pas tout
à fait dans quelles conditions c'est
assez difficile en ce moment en
Grande-Bretagne absolument donc au
niveau de la liturgie de la pompe
circonstance c'est une question qui va
devoir être débattre j'étais intéressé
pour la question du commonwell en
particulier parce que pour certains
après le brexit le commonwal c'était
peut-être la porte de sortie c'était
peut-être les pays vers lesquels
l'Angleterre allait essayer de se
tourner pour un renouveau économique que
Boris Johnson avait promis mais qui
finalement ne va pas être aussi simple
que ça les pays sont bien loin les
distances sont grandes et les atomes
crochus sont pas aussi
serrées qu'on pourrait le penser donc
des questions encore d'Empire qui sont
fondamentales dans le dans l'âme
britannique si on peut dire mais
quelquefois qui sont peut-être mal placé
et qui maintenant vont changer jusqu'à
ce que tant que la reine était vivante
au fond les questions ne se posaient
peut-être pas mais là ça s'accélère avec
l'arrivée de chat on entendait un peu
plus tôt des collaborateurs en
Nouvelle-Zélande au Kenya qui disaient
quand même qu'il y avait que ces mitigé
tout ça il y a bien sûr il y a un accord
il y a une des réaction officielles qui
sont très
louangeuses de la reine mais il y a
aussi beaucoup de gens qui se
questionnent sur tout ce qui s'est passé
elles ont en commun les ces puissances
là la démocratie les valeurs
démocratiques mais également
le système parlementaire et quand
quelqu'un offre cette règle comme Fidji
il y avait quelques décennies Fidji a
été expulsé du commonwal pendant une
période mais en même temps le
commonwealt malgré tout
fruitiers de la colonisation et donc des
héritages esclavagistes que les gens
rappellent un de vos interlocuteurs vous
parlez des indigènes en Nouvelle-Zélande
eux sont vraiment
c'est pareil en Australie aussi il y a
des revendications alors faut pas se
cacher la
Britannique a été basée sur la
spoliation il faut ajouter la Chine à ce
dossier là avec les deux guerres de
l'Opium alors il y a des il y a du
ressentiment alors il va falloir
user des diplomaties pour dire se passer
là c'est terminé restez avec nous on
partage des valeurs communes qui sont la
démocratie le régime parlementaire etc
et puis des liens économiques liens
culturels aussi la langue alors tout ça
pourrait jouer mais il faut pas imaginer
le commonwealt comment dirais comme
directement après le la colonisation il
faut démontrer ça va être la difficulté
de Charles une cigarette diplomate que
sa mère pour démontrer que non c'est en
pleine évolution rester s'il vous plaît
on va faire évoluer ça ça c'est la reine
s'excuse peut-être pour certaines des
atrocités qui ont été commises par la
Grande-Bretagne quand elle dans ses
colonies
je pense chez nous on demandait ça je
suis pas sûr qu'il a obtenu alors non
c'est difficile on peut obtenir des
réparations peut-être une considération
nos autochtones au Canada jouer c'est
une oreille de la monarchie
considérable et accès direct à la reine
il la rencontre justement à cause des
torts causés puis s'appuie sur elle à
cause des traités alors
la monarchie peut prêter une oreille
attentive à ces revendications là
montrez qu'elle va évoluer ça ça va être
le rôle de Charles dans les années à
venir mais c'est excusez
va abondamment ça aussi un certain
l'Afrique du Sud ou au pays où ils ont
été pris la plupart des des pierres
précieuses qui qui fait partie du de
tous ces couronnes c'est justement c'est
que ça a été ça a été trouvé dans les
pays africains ou aux Indes et les les
revendications sont là évidemment
la périodiquement on demande à ce que le
culinaire 2 et 1 qu'on a vu soit sur le
cercle le 1 et le 2 sur la corianne la
couronne d'appareil la couronne et
bériale d'apparent
c'est demander régulièrement ce que ça
soit retourné au pays d'origine mais
évidemment c'est
c'est certain que tant qu'à moi que ça
ne se fera pas il y aura peut-être des
excuses où il y aura peut-être on va
dire oui on comprend que c'est racheté
ou rapporté d'une façon
un peu cavalière mais ça va rester dans
le Trésor britannique c'est certain ça
se fait au compte-goutte comme au
British music où on rend parfois des
oeuvres qui appartiennent à des
civilisations antiques mais ça se fait
au conduire il faut pas ça rapidement
comme ça de même pour les joyaux de la
couronne on imagine moi je voulais je
voulais peut-être faire un parallèle
avec la Communion anglicane qui
finalement a été aussi un produit de la
colonisation si on peut dire l'église
anglicate qui a pris son essor à travers
le monde avec la colonisation en suivant
les les invasions britanniques en tout
cas la diplomatie britannique et qui
finalement maintenant dans chaque
province est devenu indépendante chaque
chaque province à ses propres sa propre
gouvernance s'organise soi-même on reste
en contact avec l'Église Mère l'Église
d'Angleterre mais même même le statut de
l'Église d'Angleterre est en train de
changer et certains demandent que la
primatie de la communion glucane puisse
être ouvert à des évêques d'ailleurs
peut-être même des évêques africains et
donc un grand changement à ce niveau là
aussi donc peut-être qu'il y aura
d'autres façons d'envisager à comme
anwars
puisque on se prépare pour cette
cérémonie cette ultime cérémonie au
château de Windsor pour rendre hommage à
la reine
Elizabeth 2 vous voyez son convoi qui
arrive on le voyait des images tout à
l'heure de cette foule massée à Windsor
c'était la langue
ou la procession il va y avoir une
cortège qui va marcher jusque jusqu'au
château de Windsor où les attentes la
famille royale en fait à partir du
château on va marcher jusqu'à la
chapelle Saint-Georges derrière ce
cortège
et on voit très bien que le corrouillard
ralenti sa vitesse pour permettre aux
gens justement qui sont le long du
trajet de pouvoir avoir un bon un bon
aperçu du cortège
je continue de jeter des fleurs des
bouquets de fleurs sur sur la voiture
quand elle passe le corbillard quand il
passe le vrai coin c'est celui-là là où
il y aura la promenade tout à l'heure
c'est fait pour ça
elle est pas très longue la promenade
mais elle permet au public de voir les
gens de la famille royale alors ça va
être l'occasion dans quelques instants
j'imagine alors je retrouve Catherine
Gauthier devant l'abbaye de Westminster
là où la cérémonie religieuse s'est
déroulée un peu plus tôt évidemment
Catherine on imagine que les Russes
vides tranquillement là où vous êtes
en fait ça s'est vidé très rapidement
Céline c'est la première fois depuis
plus d'une semaine qu'on voit les rues
complètement vides autour de Westminster
il ne reste que quelques policiers
autour de moi faut dire que c'est tout
fermé à la circulation donc évidemment
la vie va tranquillement reprendre son
cours mais les gens qui étaient
installés depuis plusieurs heures
plusieurs jours pour voir le cortège la
procession ont quitté ont pu saluer pour
une dernière fois leur reine mais là
vraiment c'est un contraste total ici
autour de Westminster Céline il faut
dire que c'est une journée férié en
Grande-Bretagne à Londres les écoles
tout est fermé les commerces et tout
donc dites moi qu'est-ce qu'on vous dit
sur on a beaucoup parlé de la reine les
Britanniques avaient une affection toute
particulière pour elle mais qu'est-ce
qu'on vous dit sur le nouveau roi sur
Charles III
écoutez quand le roi Charles III est
arrivé pour la première fois en début de
semaine au palais de Buckingham on était
là il y avait beaucoup de Britanniques
évidemment qui étaient sur place qui
venait encore déposer des germes de
fleurs autour du portail principal du
palais et quand le cortège du roi est
arrivé la foule s'est mise à applaudir
on a vraiment accueilli de façon
positive le roi Charles III on était
heureux de le voir vous souvenez-vous il
a fait ce premier bain de foule tout
près du portail de du palais de bokenia
mais les gens étaient heureux de le
saluer quand on a demandé aux gens
qu'est-ce que vous pensez du roi Charles
a demandé à plusieurs reprises à
différentes personnes et plusieurs m'ont
répondu ben écoutez c'est sûr qu'il a de
grosses chaussures à porter les
Britanniques affectionnés
particulièrement à la reine Elizabeth II
on le sait c'était le règne depuis 70
ans donc plusieurs personnes n'ont pas
connu d'autres monarques mais
s'il était peut-être un peu moins aimé
que sa mère ou en tout cas les gens Ant
son arrivée on a senti qu'on voulait lui
donner une chance ça a été toute une
semaine pour le roi Charles III le décès
de sa mère le deuil arrive mais aussi
ses nouvelles fonctions elle a été
proclam à miroir et même durant la
proclamation quand on s'est promené
autour du palais Saint-Jean le plus
vieux palais de Londres où on l'a
proclamé pour la première fois de façon
publique comme le veut la tradition il y
avait énormément de monde Céline c'était
encore une fois bouclés les petits trucs
étaient bondés on avait de la difficulté
à se déplacer alors vraiment on a
l'impression qu'on va vouloir lui donner
une chance quand même il va falloir
qu'il fasse sa place bien sûr mais cette
semaine les gens à qui on a parlé
étaient plutôt positif oui donner une
chance au coureur même si les défis
qu'il attendent on le sait sont quand
même extrêmement important
oui même si le rôle du roi est plutôt
symbolique évidemment c'est le
gouvernement qui prend les décisions
mais il est quand même bien sûr il agit
au nom du roi du monarque la crise de
l'énergie les Britanniques les temps
sont durs aussi la hausse du coût de la
vie l'inflation on sent vraiment que ces
gens-là vont avoir besoin d'un coup de
pouce et la reine elle était rassurante
elle était un peu la stabilité si on
veut du pays alors effectivement le roi
Charles III va boire beaucoup de défis
pour la suite une fois que cette
période-là de deuil et de transition
sera bien terminée il faudra voir
comment ça va se passer pour lui mais
encore le deuil national s'achève mais
il y aura une autre semaine de deuil
plus intime plus plus familiale où ils
pourront un petit peu
se souvenir de leur de la reine un peu
plus dans l'intimité parce que jusqu'ici
tout est tellement public que c'est
évidemment un poids important pour eux
merci beaucoup Catherine
ouais ça a été quand même une semaine
très chargée pour pour le nouveau roi
pour toute la famille mais c'est on
oublie un peu mais c'est vrai qu'ils
vivent ce deuil très de façon très
publique
qui peut être une circonstance
atténuante pour les sautes d'humeur les
patients un nouveau invités parlait de
ça le journaliste et c'est ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est grace under pressure ce qui
veut dire que quand vous subissez des
secousses autour de vous si vous êtes un
personnage Royal il faut que vous
gardiez votre flamme il y a eu deux
occasions de le perdre son flegme la
semaine dernière pour le truc ça se
reproduit ça il va falloir qu'il ait une
image parfaite et que son couronnement
aussi au croisement soit pas luxueux
l'État se prête pas à ça Elisabeth avait
eu un mariage très modeste on sortait de
la guerre
dans les années 50 là on commençait à
vouloir célébrer un peu plus manifester
que la Grande-Bretagne renaissait alors
le coudement lui a été célébré dans la
splendeur mais Philippe et Elisabeth ont
eu ont pris la décision d'ailleurs de
célébrer leur mariage dans une relative
simplicité et c'est peut-être là dessus
ou en haut les Anglais souffrent on en a
fait état tout au long de cette émission
c'est pas le temps de se lancer dans les
dépenses sanctuaires c'était justifié
pour le
couronnement nos propres le couronnement
pour ce qui vient de se passer les
funérailles à Westminster high c'est une
grande splendeur puis il fallait marquer
la fin du règne mais le nouveau règne
doit-il commencer avec l'extravagance il
va y avoir toute une réflexion on sait
pas quand est-ce qu'il va être couronné
ça peut prendre plusieurs mois encore
Isabelle
ça avait pris plus d'un an pour la reine
Elizabeth mais il y a quelques dans les
premiers jours
suite à la au décès de la reine on a dit
que le couronnement pourrait avoir lieu
dans environ 6 mois donc on peut on peut
estimer qu'au printemps prochain le
couronnement aura lieu mais il reste que
si certains on voit essayer de que le
couronnement soit grandiose tout en
étant sobre celui de la Reine Elizabeth
évidemment
ça a été l'événement grandiose parce que
ça a été aussi pour les Anglais la fin
du rationnement suite à la guerre la
guerre c'est terminé à 45 où il est
rationnement s'est terminé seulement en
1953 et même la reine lorsqu'elle elle
s'est mariée elle a les plusieurs femmes
lui envoyaient leurs coupons de
vêtements pour qu'elle puisse avoir une
plus belle robe elle est dit non non
j'ai ma quantité de coupon alloué pour
ma robe c'est ceux-là et uniquement
ceux-là que je vais prendre alors et le
garder elle a puisque les Anglais
vivaient mais lors du couronnement
évidemment là tout le reste seulement
était terminé et on a plus on a pu
célébrer comme seuls les Anglais peuvent
mettre préparer des cérémonies le
grandiose pour ça mais l'année prochaine
ce sera ça va être différent c'est
certain que on aura peut-être pas parce
que en 53 la télévision c'était la
première fois que le couronnement était
diffusé alors que là même la
proclamation du du roi Charles la
semaine dernière c'était la première
fois que c'était public donc la
télévision va être présente mais ça va
être fait fort probable d'une autre
façon que il y a 70 ans
dans 6 mois pensez que les Britanniques
seront sortis de leurs difficultés
économique ça me paraît utopique ils
vont encore nager dans l'inflation si la
reste c'est comme comme la récession
aussi ça émane c'est encore plus que
nous alors le roi Charles pour son
couronnement devra moduler c'est à dire
avoir une couronnement qui
conforme aux circonstances ça peut pas
être dans le faste le grand luxe
extravagant alors que les gens ont des
difficultés à arriver il ne prendrait
mal
ce qui était un homme pour un pays qui
est encore une conscience 16 ans de
l'âme de l'Empire c'est que les
Britanniques ont vendu beaucoup de leur
de leurs grands services nationaux donc
l'électricité le gaz etc tout ça c'est
dépendant de l'étranger et donc il y a
aussi un conflit un peu de l'idéologie
dans tout ça c'est que au niveau
commercial au niveau national on a
essayé ils ont essayé de d'attirer des
investisseurs étrangers mais maintenant
en période de difficulté c'est beaucoup
plus difficile de s'en sortir en
particulier l'impact de la guerre en
Ukraine et des rationnements du gaz de
Russie et très difficile sur la
on voit le corbillard donc qui est
arrivé à Windsor il est attendu pour une
procession à pied sur le long wok du
château de Windsor c'est une avenue de
plusieurs kilomètres 5 km et elle sera
abordée de membres des forces armées et
il y a des membres du public qui sont
déjà installés d'ailleurs et qui
attendent le passage de ce cortège donc
qui arrive à Windsor en ce moment
on va écouter un petit peu de ce cortège
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on voit ces images de ce cortège qui
arrive à Windsor avec
tous ces militaires en tenue
vous avez remarqué que on n'est pas mal
plus à la campagne aussi un décor et
champêtre il faut ils sont moins grandes
et ça nous fait comprendre aussi
pourquoi la reine Elisabeth avait choisi
que ces funérailles se tiennent à
l'abbaye de Moissy mystère elle aurait
pu opter pour le château de Windsor mais
non elle voulait que ça soit public au
cœur de la ville là c'est une autre
cérémonie plus dans les cadres royaux
plus dans ce cadre qu'elle aimait
d'ailleurs de la campagne
elle aimait beaucoup ce château elle
adolescente elle a été envoyée
d'ailleurs au château pendant la guerre
alors que Londres était menacé devant et
plus récemment elle en avait fait sa
résidence permanente pendant la pandémie
c'est là qu'elle a vécu c'était plus
facile pour sa garde rapprochée il y
avait seulement 7 ou 8 personnes qui
étaient autour d'elle pour
les aider à passer cette période là
alors que et tous ces gens-là étaient
confinés ensemble pendant la plus grande
période de la pandémie on va rejoindre
maintenant Philippe Crowder il est
correspondant de la Société de presse il
se trouve tout près du château de
Windsor la prochaine étape donc de cette
journée sera un service religieux à la
chapelle Saint-Georges Philippe en
premier lieu comment ça se passe autour
de vous à Windsor en ce moment quel est
l'état d'esprit
alors vous les voyez les images
magnifiques de l'arrivée de ce cortège
funèbre ici à Windsor ils sont déjà
arrivés sur ce qui s'appelle la langue
work c'est une longue route étroite qui
mène vers les grilles du château de
Windsor c'est là où le cortège sera
rejoint à l'intérieur du château de
Windsor par la foi famille royale
britannique on vient d'entendre ici les
annonces faites par haut-parleur qu'il
n'y a plus de place sur cette sur ce
long wok pour les spectateurs
quelques-uns l'avaient déjà rejoint hier
soir endormi sur place pour avoir la
meilleure point de vue pour voir passer
ce cortège et le cercueil de la Reine
Elisabeth de notre annonce qui a été
faite ici c'était que les gens ne
devraient pas jeter des fleurs sur ce
corbillard cela n'a pas eu lieu il y a
quelques fleurs qui se trouvent en ce
moment même sur ce corbillard qui est en
train d'arriver ici près de chez nous à
Windsor c'est un jour de deuil ici aussi
dans tout le Royaume-Uni et ça se
ressent ici à win vous voyez le château
derrière moi avec le drapeau c'est le
drapeau royal au-dessus du château de
Windsor cela veut dire que le roi
Charles III est déjà sur place il est
arrivé par hélicoptère pour attendre
donc le cercueil de la reine Élisabeth
dans ce domaine royal qu'elle aimait
autant et où elle a passé un beau temps
pendant ces dernières années ouais c'est
ce qu'on disait mais je regarde les
images qu'on a vu tout à l'heure les
images sur ce long work énormément de
gens qui sont massés pour voir passer le
cortège
ouais c'est impressionnant il y a plus
de place sur cette langue work un
endroit qui a été créé spécifiquement
pour ce type de procession pour ces
événements les plus importants les plus
cérémoniales de la famille royale
britannique des mariages ont eu lieu
dans cette dans cette dans ce château de
Windsor avec des processions là aussi le
mariage du prince Harry avec Meghan par
exemple des des baptêmes aussi et des
funérailles bien sûr comme celui du
prince Philippe le mari de la reine
Elizabeth I à côté duquel elle sera
enterrée plus tard ce soir vous verrez
je crois dans les prochaines minutes
encore quelques-unes des images les plus
fortes avec quelques-uns des fans les
plus réguliers de cette famille royale
qui viennent toujours ici à Windsor pour
les événements les plus importants
celui-ci probablement le plus important
de tous l'enterrement d'une reine qui
était donc qui était la monarque du
Royaume-Uni pendant 70 ouais on voit
l'ancien Premier ministre Tony Blair
alors parlez-nous du service religieux
parce que ce sera un protocole réglé au
quart de tour comme on l'a vu durant les
funéraires et comment comment ça va se
dérouler
alors tout est minutieusement organisé
pendant cette journée et pendant les
derniers 11 jours c'était un événement
il faut le dire avec la mort de la reine
à l'âge de 96 ans qui était préparé
auquel on était plus ou moins préparé
malgré le fait qu'on voit maintenant du
deuil du choc de la surprise aussi bien
sûr donc tout était est minutieusement
organisé donc le service religieux qu'on
verra qu'on verra plus tard aujourd'hui
ce sera un service religieux télévisé
qui sera dirigé par le doyen de Windsor
en présence de l'archevêque de
Canterbury les deux sont les hommes les
plus importants à côté du roi Charles
bien sûr pendant cette cérémonie
religieuse ce sera un autre rappel de la
foi de la Reine Elizabeth on l'a vu
pendant la cérémonie à l'abbaye de
Westminster c'était une une reine qui
avait beaucoup de fois qui était sur
quel serait de nouveau en présence de
son mari défunt et de parents défend
après sa mort on verra cela pendant ce
service religieux en entrant des hymnes
des chants religieux et après on verra
aussi un moment très symbolique à la fin
du règne d'une monarque comme la reine
Elisabeth II ce sera ce sera le sceptre
et la couronne qui vont qui seront qui
seront pris du
cercueil et qui du cercueil voilà ce
sera ce sera symboliquement la fin de la
du règne de la reine Elizabeth II
ensuite le cercueil va être descendu
dans la voûte royale mais ce ne sera pas
encore la toute fin de ce qui va se
passer ici à Windsor la dernière partie
ne sera pas télévisée elle ne sera pas
en public ce sera un service funèbre ce
sera l'enterrement même et pour celui-là
il n'y aura que des membres de la
famille royale pour ce service funèbre
ce service religieux à l'intérieur de
très belle de Saint-Georges il y aura
des invités pas seulement la famille
royale vous les avez vu arriver les ex
premiers ministres du Royaume-Uni par
exemple des amis aussi et des membres du
staff aussi de ce château de Windsor et
des autres domaines Royal ici au
Royaume-Uni et qu'est-ce que les gens
vous disent
quand ce qu'il y avait avec la reine
Élisabeth c'était de la constance plus
qu'autre chose parce que c'est ce qu'on
veut du roi Charles III quand on leur
demande cette question là qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent de ce règne du roi
Charles III et c'est bien et bien c'est
exactement ce qu'ils avaient avec la
reine Elizabeth II c'est de la constance
la même chose tout simplement ce sera
difficile pour le roi Charles bien sûr
parce que c'est une différence qu'il a
avec la reine Élisabeth II il a des
opinions et on compte encore roi il n'a
pas le droit aux opinions alors si on
demande quand même aux gens pourquoi ils
sont là pourquoi il y a des millions de
personnes qui sont venues non pas
seulement à Londres mais aussi ici à
Windsor et Christian d'aller voir la
chapelle ardente de la Reine Elizabeth
dans Westminster pourquoi ils y étaient
pendant ces derniers jours et bien la
raison principale c'est bien sûr pour la
commémorer mais pour aussi être là
pendant un moment historique c'est
peut-être quelque chose d'assez
britannique qu'on veut être sur place
vraiment quelque chose d'historique se
passe dans leur pays c'est ce qui se
passe maintenant et il faut le rappeler
c'est assez important les gens qui sont
allés visiter la chapelle ardentes de la
reine n'avait pas accès au téléphone
pendant cette petite visite pendant 7
minutes ou peut-être deux minutes qu'ils
ont passé en présence du cercueil à
l'intérieur de Westminster Hall c'était
pour y être eux-mêmes avec leurs pensées
pour commémorer la reine c'est assez
important parce qu'on voit toujours ces
images des gens qui photographies et qui
prennent des vidéos du du cortège ce
n'était pas le cas à Westminster il y a
du il y a du vrai deuil ici au
Royaume-Uni il y avait les gens se
recueillaient vraiment et certains
étaient vraiment visiblement triste et
attristé par tout ça on a vu des larmes
des gens pleurer Philippe Roser merci
beaucoup c'était très éclairant tout ce
que vous avez pu nous dire merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
alors des images de l'intérieur de la
chapelle Saint-Georges
et de cette cérémonie qui se prépare il
va y avoir en tout autour de 800 invités
donc Philippe nous en parlait des gens
des proches de la famille royale des
ministres on devait arriver plusieurs
membres les différentes familles royales
d'Europe le roi Guillaume Alexandre des
Pays-Bas la reine la princesse
Marguerite
de Roumanie donc ils étaient là tous
ensemble pour
se rendre directement à la chapelle et
on a demandé aux gens de ne pas jeter de
fleurs sur le corbillard mais il y en a
encore quelques-unes qui qui sont là en
les voyelles sur le sur le chemin le
long du convoi les gens jetaient des
fleurs donc Philippe parlait de Philippe
Brothers parler de la foi de la reine
elle était très croyante elle était
croyante pour elle devient monarque
c'était une vocation divine qui lui
avait été donné dont elle ne voulait pas
elle voulait continuer jusqu'à la fin et
elle l'a vraiment pris comme
[Musique]
de service si on peut dire comme ça le
monarque britannique et ouais avec de
l'huile à moment de son couronnement il
y a un côté très symboliquement
religieux dans la fonction qu'elle a
pris très sérieusement c'est une femme
qui était très régulièrement juste un
truc d'eau et Sophie Grégoire Trudeau
qui arrive donc pour cette cérémonie
de l'Église d'Angleterre elle avait un
rôle particulier vis-à-vis de vis-à-vis
de l'Église d'Angleterre donc était
nommée les évêques sous ou
selon comment dire on lui donne des
conseils bien entendu sur ces choses-là
mais elle était très proche de la
première ministre lise strass et
derrière elle la première ministre de la
Nouvelle-Zélande jasminda Harden dont on
parlait tout à l'heure
secrétaire général du commonwear
Patricia Scorpion et
son
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est à l'intérieur de la chapelle
Saint-Georges à Windsor donc on voyait
arriver les membres de la famille royale
et avant James on a vu aussi sa sœur
Flora et son mari donc c'est les cousins
de la reine qui sont
si on remonte de deux générations ils
sont des descendants de Georges V le duc
de Kent et ensuite c'est la princesse
Alexandra et ses enfants elle est
d'ailleurs
présente même si alors 83 ans et les
membres de la famille royale les plus
proches eux ils sont
vont arriver avec le cortège à pied mais
là c'est ça le sucre les enfants du duc
de classeur et leurs petits-enfants
les membres du Leroy et les membres de
la famille royale vont rejoindre le
cortège là dans les jardins du château
de Windsor dans quelques instants pour
se rendre ensuite avec ce cortège
assisté à ce
à cette messe funèbre en fait
une cérémonie funèbre oui
traditionnellement on n'aurait pas
forcément besoin de pompe et
circonstances de la même manière pour ce
stade là des funérailles mais c'est une
opportunité de rassembler les personnes
qui travaillaient au château de Windsor
de même que la famille des gens
peut-être plus proches on a parlé d'amis
aussi c'est quand même même dans un
cadre face c'est une cérémonie plus
intime c'est les gens qui côtoyaient la
reine peut-être plus qui avait une
connexion en direct et qui n'était pas
pour la plupart pas invité au service
d'état à l'abbaye de Westminster mais
encore une fois une foule immense qui se
presse pour voir passer le cortège
c'est impressionnant un cadre champêtre
comme on dit une foule énorme puis
malgré tout une certaine splendeur on
n'atteindrait pas ça nécessairement
contenu du fait qu'il y avait une
cérémonie avant mais là il y a tout un
déploiement on parlait tout à l'heure de
la foi c'est important la fois de la
souveraine mais il y a une dimension
aussi dans le cas du long règne
d'Élisabeth c'est le côté exemplaire
elle n'a jamais failli sur ce côté elle
était sur le plan du travail
d'être à son affaire d'être prévisible
d'être fiable elle était totalement
exemplaire et à partir du moment où un
monarque des roches de ça c'est un
système qui malgré tout et pas vraiment
démocratique alors
longtemps l'air plus ce qui est arrivé
j'en prends pour exemple quelqu'un qui
était à la cérémonie one Carlos
d'Espagne il était un monarque reconnu
d'ailleurs qui avait été exemplaire à
ses débuts il y avait résisté un coup
d'État à l'intérieur de son pays très
fermement mais les parties dans un
safari avec sa maîtresse
Un chasse au rhinocéros du coup il a
tout perdu
autrement dit la monarchie ça tient un
fil il faut que vous soyez parfait alors
vous avez des privilèges vous avez des
des
possibilités diplomatiques déjà c'est
beaucoup à ça se résume maintenant une
monarque ou un monarque c'est quelqu'un
qui doit faire de la diplomatie ça a été
la grande réussite des photons voir si
Charles est aussi performant sur ce
plan-là mais vous savez dimanche pouvoir
vous avez un réseau mais ça existe une
conduite vraiment exemplaire une
fonction comme celle-là
finalement c'est pour ça aussi que le
prince Charles c'est une reine qu'on
sort passe à Rennes parce que c'était un
remariage et un grand débat quelle place
allait-elle pouvoir avoir au niveau du
système monarchique et finalement on l'a
nommé redresseur à un moment à la
peut-être que princesse c'était pas très
clair vis-à-vis d'opinion publique
britannique la façon dont Charles
c'était conduit quand même ça avait
laissé beaucoup de traces donc
au moment de son jubilé je pense
porter le titre de Rennes concert mais
vous dire aussi que les années ont passé
suite bon ça fait aussi 25 ans cette
année que la princesse de Galles est
décédée la reine camélia a fait ses
preuves comme elle était vraiment un
excellent sport pour le futur roi le roi
Charles donc je crois que c'est ça aussi
que la reine évolue reconnaître c'est
que
à l'époque la duchesse de Cornouaille a
vraiment joué un rôle de support pour le
futur monarque et maintenant on sait
très bien que elle va être aussi la
personne qui va l'aider à faire
certaines transitions à être moins
soupe on peut dire sur certains
certaines pecadis alors que
ça va être ça son rôle de vraiment leur
aider à ce que tout se fasse en douceur
et non pas avec des sauts d'humeur qui
parfois peut sembler cocasses mais en
même temps donne une image un peu
négative de ce que les images
épouvantable en fin de semaine où elle
voyait s'impatienter après un stylo et
on voyait dans la gestuelle qu'il était
en colère on a dû le sortir de la pièce
et c'est Camilla qui a continué à signer
à sa place et on dit qu'elle a beaucoup
de sens d'humour qu'elle est une
personne simple qui aime les choses
rurales aussi
qui dans la vie l'amène où réalisme et
ça peut être une bonne compensation pour
lui elle faisait sa sortie en fin de
semaine nous du commonwealt plutôt que
d'Angleterre de l'avion jamais entendu
sa voix et il y a oui c'était sur les
ondes de la BBC on a entendu s'exprimer
pour la première fois Camila va être
rangement basse elle louait le regard
d'Elizabeth quand elle ouvrait les yeux
ses yeux bleus ça illuminait son visage
racontait c'était pas très long mais
c'est un premier contact en tout cas
j'imagine qu'elle va reparler il faut me
dire des choses plus substantielles déjà
on a un premier contact qui elle va
prendre sa place elle est numérique des
discrètes ça c'est habile très habile
pendant les années de controverse ne pas
être tout le temps au milieu de la place
les gens l'auraient pas accepté ça alors
les gens étaient très durs envers
on l'accusait d'avoir volé
d'avoir volé l'époux de Diana elle a eu
beaucoup de ressentiments et de
dureté à son endroit la princesse Diana
avait cristallisé ça avec une expression
de vous souvenez sans doute
pour ceux qui connaisseurs c'est un
chien très méchant alors déjà avec gardé
cette association à l'esprit quand il la
voyait ça se disciple maintenant on va
retrouver à The Voice qui est maintenant
à Trafalgar Square parce que AZ vous
avez justement couvert le mariage de de
Charles et de camilia
absolument à écouter à la sortie
justement ils se sont mariés au château
à la chapelle Saint-Georges donc à
Windsor et je me souviens qu'à la sortie
bon il y avait beaucoup de gens qui
applaudissaient mais il y avait aussi
des gens qui brandissaient des photos de
la princesse Diana donc Kamila va être
acceptée va être respectée parce que
c'est la femme que le roi Charles a
choisi mais on n'est pas certain si elle
va être aimée on n'a pas entendu
quelqu'un dire que voilà qu'elle était
adorée d'ailleurs jamais on lui a donné
le titre de princesse de Galles parce
que le roi Charles était prince de
Galles elle n'a pas eu le titre de
princesse de Galles parce que justement
ce titre c'était vraiment le titre de la
princesse Diana donc ça va prendre
certainement du temps pour Kamila avant
d'être accepté la la reine a dit que
voilà c'est la reine qu'on sort tout le
monde respecte ce que la reine dit mais
les gens c'est les gens ne n'ont pas
n'ont pas oublié Diana et ça on le
revoit à chaque fois chaque fois qu'on
parle à des Britanniques on leur parle
de Camila il y a toujours une espèce de
gêne avec tout ce qui s'est passé
évidemment avec la mort tragique de
Diana à la fin donc ça elle reste encore
et encore du travail à faire je dirais
mais comme il le disait Marc c'est un
début son entrevue à la BBC c'est la
première fois qu'on entendait sa voix et
elle a parlé de la reine avec beaucoup
d'admiration elle a parlé aussi de son
lien personnel avec avec la reine donc
on va voir elle s'était beaucoup
rapprochée de la reine au cours des
dernières années avait été elle aussi à
ses studieuse dans tout ce qu'elle avait
fait donc elle a été 10 ans Ré liberté
maintenant parlons de ce que vous avez
vu un peu plus tôt un cortège vraiment
impressionnant la Londres qui a traversé
le centre de Londres
tout à fait c'est incroyable de voir les
gens très émus c'est vraiment le les
gens sont extrêmement émus parce qu'ils
se disent c'est la dernière fois qu'ils
verront leur reine c'est le qui a
toujours été ici là je me trouve à
chauffeur et vous pouvez vous voir
derrière moi là il y a quand même de
l'action il y a toujours une forte
présence policière mais je vous dirais
Céline qui environ 10 minutes toutes les
rues étaient fermées et c'était
complètement désert ici pendant la
procession pendant que le cortège le
cercueil de la reine traversait les rues
de Londres il n'y a toujours pas de
voiture mais voilà c'est ça a été un
moment assez solennel partout dans
Londres et puis on parlait à certaines
personnes qui nous disaient vous savez
la reine avec tout ce qui se passe en
Europe avec l'extrême droite qui monte
la reine est toujours une référence
politique pour vous parler de sa foi
tout à l'heure les gens quel que soit
les politiciens qui soient de droite qui
soit extrêmement populiste même avec le
brexit ils avaient toujours cette espèce
de
d'assurance que et que tout va bien
aller malgré le genre de politiciens qui
vont avoir été un peu vrai pour toute
l'Europe quand Emmanuel Macron a dit au
Britannique c'était votre reine mais
pour nous c'était la reine elle était
une référence pour beaucoup de chefs
d'État pour beaucoup de repères en
général parce que justement elle était
un peu au-dessus des politiques et
aujourd'hui avec toute la vague
d'extrême droite qui monte bah c'est
cette référence qui est un peu perdue il
y avait cette femme que sur la sur les
ondes de la BBC elle a marre ce qui
disait que ses parents étaient des
survivants de l'Holocauste et qu'en fait
le fait que la monarchie la reine était
en Angleterre et disait c'était toujours
une assurance pour nous on a trouvé un
endroit en Europe où on allait être en
sécurité en fait parce que évidemment
ils ont sa famille avait vécu le low
cost donc elle disait que le départ de
la reine ça pose un peu d'insécurité
avec tout ce qui se passe en Europe avec
la crise économique on a toujours peur
qu'il y a encore des mouvements
d'extrême droite qui prennent de
l'ampleur donc
cette espèce aussi de d'insécurité à ce
niveau là
très bien merci
alors voilà c'est un peu cet homme avait
ce sentiment là par rapport à la reine
et c'est un peu partagé par par beaucoup
par beaucoup de Britanniques et tout le
monde regarde le roi Charles III on l'a
vu perdre un peu patience avec son stylo
marque en a parlé tout à l'heure et la
reine vous savez pendant ce cas vraiment
ça a changé
où est-ce que c'est juste anecdotique
parce que bon c'était voilà et puis il
excuse parce qu'il est quand même en
deuil elle vient de perdre sa mère donc
les gens sont quand même extrêmement
indulgents c'est encore trop tôt pour le
juger mais quand même c'était un faux
pas et la première tâche du roi Charles
c'est aussi d'organiser ces funérailles
d'État que ça se passe bien qui est une
transition très douce et puis maintenant
pour la famille royale évidemment ce
sera le temps de vraiment faire son
deuil personnel par rapport à la reine
très bien merci beaucoup à Z
voilà ce cortège qui se dirige lentement
vers le château de Windsor c'est un peu
plus lent que prévu jusqu'ici tout était
très très minutieusement préparé mais là
on a pris un petit peu de retard le
convoi donc il devrait arriver sous peu
au château de Windsor il sera rejoint
par la famille royale et ensuite se
dirigera vers la chapelle Saint-Georges
ou aura lieu un service funèbre un peu
plus tard en soirée
la reine sera éliminée aux côtés de son
mari le prince Philippe son père Édouard
VI et la reine mère ainsi que Margaret
donc dans la chapelle Georges VI
et c'est une petite chapelle à
l'intérieur de la chapelle Windsor mais
c'est tout petit et c'est ça il y a
l'espace pour le roi George 6 la reine
Elizabeth la reine mère et on va aussi
placer le cercueil de la Reine Elizabeth
et du prince Philippe ce soir lors de la
cérémonie privée on va les dépôts les
dessins dans cette petite chapelle et il
va avoir aussi
les cendres de la princesse Marguerite
qui sont déjà là depuis 2002 donc
plusieurs moments très forts dans cette
cérémonie notamment quand on va
retirez du du cercueil le sceptre et
l'orme ainsi que la couronne de la reine
c'est le Joyet de la monarchie donc qui
vient récupérer c'est joyeux de la
monarchie oui et c'est le moment où
vraiment le règne de la reine Elizabeth
se termine c'est au moment où c'est
bijoux d'État sont retirés du cercueil
et ils vont être évidemment
rapportés à Londres pour à la Tour de
Londres on va y avoir les mêmes objets
ou couronnement dans 6 mois pense-t-on
alors oui le symbolisme
à Charles
c'est à partir de George carte que cette
chapelle la grande chapelle n'ont pas la
petite là qui sert de crypte
a servi et le roi George IV s'est isolé
de Londres à partir de cette période sur
la recommandation de sa femme d'ailleurs
et par la suite ont établi leur
résidence là-bas ça a été une transition
par 40 monarques depuis 1000 ans ce
château
[Musique]
donc quel genre de service
cette fois-ci on vient pour apporter le
corps de sa Majesté à son dernier sa
place sur l'endroit de dernière repos
donc que mettons en anglais on essayait
de trouver une traduction tout à l'heure
plus précise en français c'est un peu
compliqué mais c'est ça on vient
apporter le corps on a remis l'âme de la
souveraine à Dieu au service à westmins
rabais et ici c'est la fin corporelle si
on peut dire et donc on va la laisser et
c'est la transition on reprend ses
symboles d'office comme on vient de le
dire et le corps sera laissé là et on
passe à autre chose donc
quand même dans le phase de
circonstances si on peut dire parce que
on reprend des thèmes qui auront été
déjà
abordés à Westminster B beaucoup de gens
des prières à nouveau une opportunité
pour les homonies Royaux de participer
aussi qui n'ont pas participé au service
de la cathédrale de l'abbaye de
Westminster donc que le staff de la gare
de la Révolution peut dire les hommes et
royaux sont sont nommés par la couronne
pour officier dans les chapelles royales
souvent sont même des homonies
militaires donc qui ont des fonctions
occasionnoriques mais qui font partie de
son staff et qui la conseille
spirituellement en même temps qu'être en
charge des chapelles royales à travers
le Royaume-Uni
on va rejoindre notre collègue
Marie-Isabelle parce que des marisabelle
parce que des rassemblements ont lieu un
peu partout dans le monde pour rendre
hommage à Elisabeth II en attendant donc
ce qu'on voit se rendre jusqu'à
l'intérieur du château où il sera
rejoint par la famille royale royale
Marie-Isabelle voilà donc il y a eu des
hommages donc des gens qui sont
rassemblés parfois dans des bars dans
des cérémonies religieuses aussi qui ont
eu lieu ici c'est à Sydney en Australie
donc des gens qui sont rassemblés dans
un bar pour regarder en direct les
funérailles de la reine à Washington
aussi même chose encore une fois dans un
bar des gens qui sont qui sont
rassemblés c'était hier quand même mais
bon les gens tiennent à rendre hommage
ces images ont été captées à Hong Kong
pendant les 10 derniers jours les gens
sont venus déposer des fleurs devant le
consulat britannique à Hong Kong alors
toutes sortes de mots qu'on y voit des
gens qui ont déposé des fleurs à leur
voyage il vraiment beaucoup et des gens
qui ont fait la file très longtemps à
Hong Kong pour aller déposer ses fleurs
ici à Bahreïn ben aujourd'hui il y a une
cérémonie avec des ressortissants
britanniques des expatriés qui ont tenu
une cérémonie religieuse encore une fois
en hommage à Elisabeth II et je vous
montre ces images capter au métro de
Paris aujourd'hui c'est surtout parce
que les publicités donc au métro on a
mis ces
pancartes géante noir en hommage à
Elisabeth II un peu la même chose aussi
au Piccadilly Circus qui est un endroit
central quand même à Londres voyez
normalement on y voit des publicités ici
c'est complètement noir avec les dates
donc de la reine Elizabeth II ça date de
naissance et sa date de décès donc
c'était assez calme aussi dans les rues
de Londres aujourd'hui voyez pas
beaucoup de gens beaucoup de commerces
qui étaient fermés d'ailleurs en cette
journée donc de deuil des fleurs qui ont
été déposées donc vous voyez ici des
annonces pour dire que plusieurs
commerces sont fermés et je termine en
vous montrant cette photo assez
marquante c'est la princesse Charlotte
qui n'a pas pu retenir ses pleurs en
sortant de l'église de la cathédrale
tout à l'heure ce matin elle était
présente donc avec son frère Georges les
deux qui ont assisté à la cérémonie le
plus jeune donc le troisième frère Louis
4 ans n'a pas assisté à la cérémonie au
funérailles mais Charlotte et Georges
qui étaient présents aujourd'hui donc
pour pour les funérailles de leur
arrière-grand-mère Charlotte qui a 7 ans
donc merci Marie-Isabelle donc on peut
imaginer à quel point c'est ça peut être
difficile de suivre comme ça
des funérailles les funérailles de son
arrière-grand-mère
qu'elle a bien connu quand pour toutes
ces années en fait depuis qu'elle est
enfant
vivre des funérailles comme ça déjà en
privé c'est difficile mais sous la
lumière des projecteurs si on peut dire
même si elle a pas forcément confiance
de conscience de ce que c'est ça mais je
disais ça ça va être la photo de main
dans les premières pages et jaunes je
pense parce que
il y avait pas beaucoup d'émotions enfin
rien qui transparaissait tellement quoi
de la part des femmes
c'est son premier contact avec la mort
et elle réalise que son
arrière-grand-mère et d'une famille
privilégie d'avoir connu son
arrière-grand-mère et particulièrement
cette arrière-grand-mère qui était très
attentive aux enfants alors c'est un
deuil personnel elle réalise ce que
c'est là alors oui
elle exprime au fond ce qu'on a pas vu
beaucoup lors de cette cérémonie ça se
traduit à travers elle déjà
les caméras ont fait et on fait
extrêmement attention pour justement ne
pas montrer les membres de la famille
qui exprime qui pleurait ou ça a été la
même chose lors des funérailles de la
princesse de Galles on n'a pas les
caméras avaient été les caméraman avait
averti de ne pas montrer la famille
parce que justement il pouvait avoir des
moments de tristesse de pleurs donc on
évite de montrer ce type de photos là on
va plutôt mettre les caméras sur
d'autres membres de la communauté qui
assistent à la cérémonie ou il y a moins
de il y aura moins de plats au vraiment
mais tout à l'heure on pouvait voir
quand même que le prince Charles était
très affecté
de la cérémonie de
vous en souvenez il y avait beaucoup
beaucoup d'émotions de fait kalton John
a chanté
[Musique]
qui a eu des discours où on puisait pas
nécessairement dans les Psaumes pour
dire qu'elle était la princesse des
cœurs il y avait il y avait un
témoignage très très personnalisé qui
portait à l'émotion
avec cette fois-ci qui a changé des
circonstances dans lesquelles est décédé
sans doute aussi
des funérailles britanniques après parce
que il y avait pas beaucoup jusqu'à ce
moment-là de témoignages personnel qui
venait du cœur etc sont fait quand son
frère a parlé c'était presque des
critiques directes de la monarchie ici
il avait c'était pas
beaucoup enfin c'était contrôlé mais
quand même il était allé plus loin qu'on
aurait pu penser pour quelque chose
d'aussi publique et la façon dont il y a
eu ce deuil collectif ça a été très très
important ça fait 25 ans et on s'en
souvient encore et on en parle toujours
et c'est encore présent dans avec ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui et si je peux
recourir un ouvrage de fiction mais bien
documenté le film de Queen on voit le
frein sup qui parle de ces funérailles
de Diana qu'on prépare alors vous allez
inviter des artistes et puis des gays et
tout ça c'est pas le genre de
funérailles que j'aime etc il avait mais
au fond c'était une funéraille plus
ouverte moins traditionnelle
et
cet épisode dans The Queen quand même
écrit par un cinéaste formidable qui a
un dramaturge aussi qui assez fidèle à
l'histoire très produisait bien les
réticences qu'il va y avoir dans
l'infirmière royale pour ce genre de
funérailles un peu plus émotive un peu
plus excitant
les codes de la famille royale on se
souvient moi je me suis avoir couvert
une visite de Diana et de Charles ici au
Canada et de la voir tendre les bras
vers ses enfants qui courait vers elle
sur le fameux bateau
où ils habitaient et c'était tout à fait
contraire encore une fois à la façon
dont on était habitué de voir la famille
royale elle elle avait un peu bousculé
les codes et beaucoup de gens l'aimaient
justement pour ça probablement
le dépoussiérage aussi de la monarchie
le fait que elle
elle était un point d'attraction
de fait on le dit souvent mais qu'elle
se elle s'impliquait dans des oeuvres
caritatives humanitaires avec les idées
d'abord ensuite avec les gens qui
avaient été victimes de mes
antipersonnelle elle allait visiter dans
les hôpitaux et leur serrer la main tout
ça ça touchait les gens là il la voyait
différemment puis le fait qu'elle était
victime malgré tout écouter on a vu tous
vu l'entrevue à panorama où elle
décrivait sa situation matrimoniale et
la manière dont on la percevait
c'est qu'elle avait été comme tassé là
et sans ménagement alors les gens
étaient plutôt de son côté tout ça a
fait que la richesse du personnage à la
fois dévoué et victime tout ça a fait
que les gens s'associent beaucoup à elle
beaucoup plus qu'un autre membres de la
famille royale alors et ça a donné
l'occasion à un des faux pas un des
rares faut pas de la reine puisqu'elle
n'a pas voulu tout de suite
on se déplace pas pour un endroit Royal
on ne fait pas le deuil pour les
non-voyants il y a deux de ces fils qui
lui ressemblent qui ont les deux
facettes le plus traditionnelles William
et l'autre Harry le plus rebelle ils
vont chercher deux côtés différents de
Diana tous les deux
avec les résultats qu'on connaît
plus depuis un certain temps mais enfin
il y aura peut-être un petit
rapprochement là
donc ce qu'on voit ce cortège qui
continue sa langue procession vers le
château de muzan on est à l'intérieur de
l'enceinte maintenant
et donc très bientôt la famille royale
va se joindre il va marcher derrière les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors vous les avez vu le roi les
membres de la famille royale ont rejoint
le cortège à l'intérieur dans le
quadrangle du château de Windsor vous
avez entendu aussi les cloches chaque
minute des des salves de canon également
le cercueil va ensuite arriver à la
chapelle Saint-Georges pour un service
funèbre et on le disait le Saint-Georges
c'est l'église choisie par la famille
royale pour les mariages les baptêmes
les funérailles c'est là que le duc et
la duchesse de sois sex le prince Harry
et Meghan se sont mariés en 2018 et
c'est là aussi que les funérailles du
mari de la reine le défunt Marie de la
reine le prince Philippe ont eu lieu
souvenez peut-être Céline que vous avez
parlé du mariage Harry et Megan qui
avait été célébré là combien c'était nos
conventionnel il y avait eu ce
prédicateur
d'origine africaine qui avait pas mal
bousculé les rites et qui apostrophe
directement les gens dans la salle ça ça
nous sortait de la liturgie habituelle
c'était ça avait vraiment surpris tout
le monde et on avait été bousculé par ça
c'était vraiment une cérémonie non
conventionnelle malheureusement les
relations sont refroidies on se disait
ah c'est peut-être l'espoir puisque tant
de gens du commonwealt qui sont
d'origine
afro-américains africains pourquoi
est-ce qu'on irait pas quelqu'un
d'origine afro-américaine dans la
famille mais à ce jour ça n'a
malheureusement pas fonctionné mais une
belle chance
les vacances de l'église
anglicane des États-Unis puisque père il
a une charge des États-Unis donc qui
avait fait certainement
mais c'était une arôme sur l'amour aussi
c'était c'était extraordinaire de
direction c'était très direct et tout ce
qui entourait aussi ce serment ou enfin
il a la musique tout avait été tellement
différent et c'est vrai que à ce
moment-là il y avait suscité un certain
espoir d'ouverture de modernisation de
la monarchie
[Musique]
mais c'était avant cette grande
querelle
ce schisme dans la famille royale une
une de plus enfin un problème de plus
pour la famille royale donc parlons un
petit peu c'est le service une élève va
être dirigé par le doyen Windsor David
corners avec la bénédiction de la
cheville de Canterbury Justin walbi qui
sera là également et ce sera suivi par
une par une congrégation un peu plus
restreinte que ce qu'on a vu à
Westminster donc 800 invités qui
attendent déjà dans la chapelle
c'est une plus intime les gens qui ont
été la femme des familles royales
d'Europe ou du monde mais aussi des
personnes qui travaillent au château de
Windsor des personnes qui ont été
connectées directement avec la reine ces
employés c'est des gens qui ont
travaillé dans le savoir et donc des
gens que la côtoyé régulièrement qui
n'ont pas eu l'opportunité participer au
funérailles à West et donc qu'il a une
opportunité de se rassembler je pense
aussi à ces homonies royaux donc on en
parlait tout à l'heure qui ont la charge
de tester chapelle des monarques à
travers le Royaume-Uni et dont on va
voir une représentation et qui vont
participer au prière aussi donc une
seconde pas vraiment funéraire mais en
continuant de funérailles pour ici la
mise au tombeau si on peut dire de la
reine c'est vraiment le dernier acte
qui va se jouer cet après-midi avec le
jeune prince Georges qui arrive
avec sa mère et la reine
et la princesse
il y a déjà une trentaine de rois qui
sont à part les personnages célèbres
comme justement Wellington mais il peut
y avoir de place et puis la tradition
récente à partir de Georges IV c'est
plutôt d'aller dans
de prendre racine si j'ose dire aux
chanteuses tradition aussi
la couronne le sceptre et le globe alors
les joyaux de la couronne symboles du
pouvoir souverain de l'autorité de la
souveraine
et on disait que c'est
joyeux de la monarchie seront transmis à
Charles lors de son couronnement
celle-là a été un peu rafistolé il y a
eu plusieurs bricolages mais celle-là va
être administrée lors d'une ça c'est la
couronne de l'État sauf erreur mais
tandis que l'autre celle de Saint-Éloi
on voit le l'appliquer sur la tête de
chat c'est la seule fois lors de son
règne au moment de son couronnement
[Musique]
aussi important mais c'est avoir l'accès
de pouvoir les sortir déjà de la Tour de
Londres d'avoir toute l'appareil qui les
apporte au bon moment qui fait que ça
légitime le pouvoir c'est la personne
qui peut donner ses ordres là qui a le
pouvoir finalement de l'autorité de
prendre cette autorité de la menace
comme c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi pendant
la Révolution après Charles 1er
crois-moi c'était remplacer de détruire
la couronne de disperser les bijoux et
on par la suite les Britanniques ont
pris leur revanche non mais on fait un
procès on condamné puis on reconstituer
la couronne mais effectivement
il s'attaquaient au symbole en
détruisant la couronne il pensait qu'il
détruisait encore plus la monarchie mais
elle s'est reconstituée avec Charles II
[Musique]
donc après cette cérémonie Estelle
qu'est-ce qui va se passer précisément
ils vont à la toute fin de la cérémonie
le cercueil de la Reine Elizabeth va
être descendu dans la crypte dans la
voûte royale et là évidemment mon la
cérémonie comme tel va être terminée
mais plus tard en soi et
cette cérémonie-là ne sera pas télévisée
et c'est les membres de la famille les
proches qui vont retourner à la chapelle
Saint-Georges et là ils vont remonter le
cercueil de la Reine Elizabeth et du
prince Philippe pour les amener dans la
chapelle à petit-chapelle qui s'appelle
le George VI le mémoriage de justice où
sont déjà le roi George c'est la reine
Elisabeth la reine mère et la princesse
Marinette donc mais cette cérémonie là
que lieu dans environ trois ou quatre
après la fin de cette cérémonie ça va se
faire en privé et vraiment c'est
seulement les intimes qui vont y
participer et ça va être pour la famille
vraiment le dernier à Dieu à la reine à
leur mère grand-mère par certains
vous parlez de la foi de la reine tout à
l'heure mais les Britanniques ne sont
pas pratiquantes tellement la pratique
religieuse en commentaire a beaucoup
baissé c'est sûr mais beaucoup de dans
le dans les recensements qui ont lieu
tous les 10 ans il y a toujours une
question au niveau de la religion et
beaucoup de Britanniques
pensent toujours aussi se décrivent
comme étant membre de l'Église
d'Angleterre qui est l'église établie
même s'ils ne viennent pas à l'église
donc la pratique religieuse est
probablement autour de 5 à 10% toutefois
confondus pour le reste c'est compliqué
mais la l'Église d'Angleterre et un
briquet dans dans tout le pays donc
participe à beaucoup est impliqué dans
les écoles et est là pour tout le monde
en fait administre le système des
paroisses donc et là pour
s'assurer ou pour s'assurer du bien-être
de toutes les personnes du royaume
cette semaine deuil cette période de
deuil a permis au Britannique de faire
non pas une fuite en avant par rapport à
leurs problèmes économique politique
aussi mais une fuite en arrière c'est à
dire on revoit ce règne on revoit le
passé de cette reine on revoit la
famille royale mais demain matin demain
matin le mal de tête revient peut-être
là on a tous ces problèmes là mais on
n'y a pas pensé pendant jusqu'à
maintenant on parle de tout à fait autre
chose l'important c'est de marquer ce
règne ce qui est important toujours
qui transportait cercueil
on l'a déjà dit mais très lourd parce
que c'est un cercueil de bois mais
doublé de plombs façon à ce qu'il soit
hermétique
pour préserver le monde
parce que
son pas enterrés ils sont laissés
en dehors de la terre
c'est du chêne anglais c'est un bois qui
est assez rare et il est justement avec
du plomb pour justement garder ce qui
soit très hermétique et
lorsqu'ils vont être déposé dans la
petite chapelle Georges VI
si vous voulez bien on va regarder et
écouter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quoi
[Musique]
plus
nous sommes réunis
l'âme de sa servante la reine Elizabeth
ici dans la chapelle Saint-Georges où
est la si souvent célébrée son culte
nous ne pouvons que penser à quelqu'un
dont la foi chrétienne simple mais
profonde apporter tant de fruits
des fruits dans une vie de service
ininterrompus à la nation au commonwald
et au monde entier
mais aussi
pour qu'on se souvienne d'elle en ce
lieu dans la gentillesse la sollicitude
et la tension rassurante pour sa famille
ses amis et ses voisins
dans notre monde qui évolue si
rapidement
nous réfléchissons à tout cela nous
avons confiance
grâce à elle en l'avenir nous pouvons
l'affronter avec courage et espoir
avec des cœurs reconnaissants
nous réfléchissons à tout cela et à
toutes les autres façons dont sa langue
vie a été une bénédiction pour nous nous
prions pour que Dieu nous donne la grâce
donnerait sa mémoire en suivant son
exemple et que avec notre sœur Elisabeth
nous connaissions enfin les joies de la
vie éternelle
[Musique]
alors j'ai vu un ciel nouveau et une
terre nouvelle
car le premier ciel et la première terre
s'en était allée et de mère il n'y en
avait plus
je l'ai vu moi John la Jérusalem
nouvelle je l'ai vu qui descendait du
ciel tout près de Dieu prête pour les
noces comme une épouse Paris pour son
mari
et j'entendis une voix forte qui venait
du trône elle disait voici la demeure de
Dieu avec les hommes il demeurera avec
eux et il se rend ses peuples
et lui-même Dieu avait que sera leur
dieu
un coach away toute larme de leurs yeux
il n'y aura plus de deuil ni de cris
ni de douleur
s'en est allé
alors celui qui siégeait sur le trône
déclara
voici que je fais toute chose nouvelle
il dit
car ces paroles sont dignes de foi est
vrai puis il me dit c'est fait moi je
suis l'alpha et la méga le commencement
et la fin
moi je donnerai l'eau de la source de
vie gratuitement
tel sera l'héritage du vainqueur je
serai sans Dieu et lui sera mon fils
souviens-toi seigneur de ta servante
Elisabeth qui nous a précédé avec le
signe de la foi et qui repose maintenant
dans le sommeil
selon tes promesses accorde lui
ainsi qu'à tous ceux qui reposent dans
le Christ le rafraîchissement la lumière
et la paix
par le même Jésus-Christ notre Seigneur
AMEN
[Musique]
et seigneur de toute vie
nous te louons de nous avoir créé à ton
image et de refléter ta vérité et ta
lumière
nous te remercions tous particulièrement
pour la vie de ta fille Elisabeth
pour la miséricorde qu'elle a reçu de
toi et pour l'exemple qu'elle a donné
à nos yeux par sa vie de service d'amour
et de foi par-dessus tout nous nous
réjouissons
de ta gracieuse promesse à tous tes
serviteurs vivants
et disparu
que nous ressusciterons à la venue de
notre Sauveur Jésus-Christ
nous prions pour que en temps voulu nous
puissions partager avec notre sœur cette
vision plus claire lorsque nous verrons
ton visage dans le même Jésus-Christ
notre Seigneur AMEN
au Père de tous
nous te prions pour ceux que nous aimons
mais que nous ne voyons plus
accorde-leur la paix
la lumière perpétuelle
et dans ta sagesse immense est à toute
puissance
accomplie en eux les bons dessins de ta
volonté parfaite par Jésus-Christ notre
Seigneur AMEN
Seigneur
soutien nous tout au long du jour de
cette vie troublée jusqu'à ce que les
ombres s'allongent et que le soir
viennent
que le monde occupé se taise que la
fièvre de la vie soit passée et que
notre travail soit terminé alors
seigneur dans Ta miséricorde
accorde-nous un logement sûr un saint
repos et la paix à la fin par
Jésus-Christ notre Seigneur AMEN
Seigneur Dieu tout-puissant roi de la
création
bénie notre roi et tous les membres de
la famille royale
que la piété soit leur guide que la
sainteté soit leur force que la paix sur
la terre soit le fruit de leur travail
et leur joie au ciel tendons éternel par
Jésus-Christ notre Seigneur amen
que Dieu sauve notre gracieuse
souveraine et tous les compagnons
vivants et disparus du très honorable et
noble ordre de la Jarretière AMEN
nous prions
notre Père qui est au cieux que ton nom
soit sanctifié que ton règne vienne que
ta volonté soit faite sur la terre comme
au ciel donne-nous aujourd’hui notre
pain quotidienne pardonne-nous nos
offenses comme nous pardonnons à ceux
qui nous ont offensés et ne nous soumets
pas à la tentation mais délivre-nous du
mal
car c'est à toi qu'appartiennent le
règne la puissance et la gloire pour des
siècles des siècles Amen
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le Seigneur aime avec tendresse ce qui
le respectent
il sait bien de quoi nous sommes faits
il se souvient que c'est un peu de
poussière
la vie humaine est comme l'herbe elle
ressemble à la fleur des champs
il commence à fleurir puis souffle le
vent elle disparaît
on ne sait même plus où elle était
seigneur dur depuis toujours et durera
toujours pour ceux qui le respectent
il reste sans cesse fidèle pour ses
enfants et les enfants de leurs enfants
va au devant de ton voyage de ce monde
au âme chrétiennes ou non de dieu le
Père tout-puissant qui t'a créé
au nom de Jésus-Christ qui a souffert
pour toi
de l'Esprit Saint qui te fortifie
une communion en communion avec les
saints bénis et avec l'aide des anges et
des Archanges et de toutes les armées de
l'armée céleste que ta part soit
aujourd'hui dans la paix
et à demain dans la Jérusalem céleste
AMEN
il a plu à Dieu tout-puissant
d'arracher à cette vie éphémère pour la
confier à sa Divine Miséricorde feu la
très haute la très puissante et la
tresse excellente monarque Elisabeth II
et de ses autres royaumes et territoires
défenseur de la foi et souveraine du
très noble ordre de la jarretière
[Musique]
de bénir d'une longue vie d'une bonne
santé donneur et de tout le bonheur du
monde le très haut le très puissant le
très excellent monarque notre souverain
seigneur
Charles III par la grâce de Dieu du
Royaume-Uni de Grande-Bretagne et
d'Irlande du Nord et de ses autres
royaumes et territoires rois chef du
commonwalt défenseur de la foi et
souverain du très noble ordre de la
jarretière
soyez courageux
ce qui est bon
ne rendait à personne le mal pour le mal
fortifié ceux qui ont le cœur fragile
soutenez les faibles aider les affliger
honorer tous les peuples aimer et servez
le Seigneur dans la joie et la puissance
de l'Esprit Saint
de Dieu tout-puissant le Père le Fils et
le Saint-Esprit soit parmi vous et
demeure avec vous pour toujours
AMEN
[Musique]
é
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de ce service funèbre
donc vous avez vu que il y avait
plusieurs traditions qui symbolisaient
la fin du règne de la reine on a vu la
couronne impériale ainsi que le globe et
le sceptre du souverain qui ont été
retirés du dessus du cercueil par le
bijoutier de la couronne ça c'est pas
ainsi la reine en fait de sa couronne
pour la dernière fois et puis le roi
ensuite placé sur le cercueil le drapeau
de la compagnie de la reine les
grenadiers girls et ensuite bon le
la reine a été descendue dans le caveau
royal et on a vu ces images très fortes
encore une fois du corps de museur de la
souveraine qui a joué une bénédiction
pendant qu'on voit les images de du
prince Harry et de Meghan Markle qui
était donc assisté à cette service
funèbre un peu plus tôt le prince
William a quitté avec son épouse avec
les deux enfants donc présent Charlotte
et
Georges qui étaient présents pour cette
cérémonie donc un petit mot révérend sur
ce qu'on vient à ce à quoi on vient
d'assister une très belle cérémonie qui
marque la fin de règne comme on l'a vu
le cercueil est descendu c'est un point
d'orgue sur
70 ans qui ont marqué le Royaume-Uni
certainement qui a marqué le monde et
donc là maintenant
on se trouve dans le règne de Charles
III ça y est c'est fait et maintenant
comme on en a parlé tout à l'heure quel
est l'avenir pour la monarchie
britannique c'est le point
d'interrogation sur lequel on va
certainement rester aujourd'hui dans un
circonstances dans le monde qui a bien
changé depuis l'arrivée de la Reine
Elizabeth
pendant qu'on voit les les invités les
dignitaires quitter cette chapelle
Saint-Georges donc c'était quand même un
moment émouvant de voir
le cercueil de la reine descendre comme
ça même si ça a été fait de façon assez
discrète dans l'église très discret mais
en même temps c'était la fin du
cérémonial et là on voit les les petites
filles les filles du prince Andrew qui
quitte mais moi ce qui m'a qui m'a
retenu c'est à la toute fin l'émotion du
roi Charles on sentait très très bien là
que il clignait souvent des yeux pour
essayer de retenir cela
ce qui frappe dans tout ça au terme de
cette deuxième cérémonie c'est la
capacité d'attraction de la
Grande-Bretagne d'abord d'organisation
tout seul le seul
accrochage c'est la longueur du deuxième
défilé qui est effectivement nous fait
un peu décalé tout le monde un peu tout
le monde qui suit ça mais dans
l'ensemble c'était superbement organisé
la force d'attraction c'est à dire que
plusieurs pays à travers la planète qui
ne sont pas des démocraties tiennent à
venir en Grande-Bretagne pour être
présent là sa crédité être là avec les
puissantes ce monde et
malgré tout c'est pas des nécessairement
des pays qui partagent les mêmes valeurs
mais ils veulent être là il ils veulent
être parti à tout ça c'est ça qui frappe
et la Grande-Bretagne est dans si vous
regardez par exemple sur la puissance
économique de ce pays son influence on
met le rôle de la Grande-Bretagne et de
la France au sein du Conseil de sécurité
sont des lorsqu'on guère mondiale mais
ce ne sont plus les grandes puissances
économiques le Japon justement la Chine
se sont elles les grands puissances
économiques mais pourtant elle sait
comment la Grande-Bretagne organisée des
cérémonies comme celle-là de façon
totalement impeccable ou presque et elle
s'est attirée les gens les jeunes les
gens tenaient même des gens encore une
fois qui partagent pas véritablement les
mêmes valeurs mais on voulait être là
pour pour signifier sa présence et son
adhésion à ce monde-là c'est une forme
de reconnaissance pour ces pays-là que
de participer à tout ça c'est étonnant
quand même qu'au 21e siècle on en soit
encore là c'est à dire que qu'un
personnage que cette femme a ses frêle
dans les dernières années de sa vie
puisse justement réunir autour d'elle le
dirigeant du monde entier quand même une
femme qui n'exerçait pas de pouvoir
politique qui exerçait un pouvoir
symbolique diplomatique on va découvrir
ça avec les années c'est à dire que pour
recréer le commonwalt après la solution
de l'Empire britannique et tout ça c'est
passé au début de son règne là elle a
pas perdu contact avec les pays en
question et le garder des liens et
contrairement justement on exposait ça
plutôt la méthode de Vladimir Poutine
c'est-à-dire on veut vous garder dans
notre empire mais de force non c'était
la manière 12 diplomatique de les amener
dans le commonweet les amener à changer
leur manière de faire en ce qui concerne
l'aparthèse la manière de quand par
exemple certains protestes contre
l'esclavagisme bon ils ont passé un
mauvais quart d'heure Jean de la famille
royale dans les Caraïbes mais ils ont
changé leur discours aussi alors et on
sent quelque chose se prépare de ce
côté-là la force d'Elisabeth II ça a été
d'être une grande diplomate on dirait
pas de pouvoir mais au moins celui-là de
créer des liens de les conserver et
c'est ce qui est souhaitable au fond que
que Charles puisse bénéficier de la même
habilité
ma chérie va défendre des causes
l'environnement pas de manière aussi
ouverte et claire et pourra pas
il pourra officiellement parfois donner
un appui moral mais il pourra pas
intervenir dans le débat politique mais
sa force si l'exerce bien ça va être au
sein de la diplomatie pour reconstituer
les commandes le maintenir en réalité
l'empêcher de se désagréger on entendait
tous ces gens parler Estelle de de la
reine qui était un peu qui faisait un
peu partie de la famille c'est ce que
beaucoup de gens ont dit soit quand ils
ont assisté au passage du cortège ou
soit quand ils étaient dans ses fils à
attendre pour essayer de voir la reine à
quel point elle avait une place
importante dans leur vie et ça je pense
que ça a marqué beaucoup beaucoup de
gens non seulement pas seulement
Grande-Bretagne non non partout même si
les gens des autres pays voyaient ça
traîne comme vraiment une femme qui
pouvait rassembler mais en même temps
qu'il y avait
cette façon d'être que tout le monde
retrouvait surtout dans les 20 30
dernières années retrouvaient une
grand-mère une femme qui était quand
même loin par rapport à sa fonction mais
proche par ces gestes et lorsque on le
vu dans l'année passée aller dans des
résidences de personnes âgées et bon
parler avec chacun même moment donné il
y a quelqu'un qui sont celles-là
ressembler
ces objets qui nous dérangent et bon
alors ces petits geste façon d'être
c'est ce que les gens se souviennent et
c'est ce qu'ils aimaient elle avait une
fonction extrêmement
symbolique mais en même temps elle a été
capable d'aller vers le peuple et les
Britanniques aujourd'hui lui rendre cet
hommage qui est bien mérité dans ce dans
ce qu'a dit l'évêque d'évite Connors
tout à l'heure il disait au coeur d'un
monde en rapide mutation
calme et digne nous a permis de garder
confiance on a beaucoup parlé de la
stabilité qu'elle a apporté de cette
unité aussi qu'elle a pas su préserver
et de l'expérience qu'elle avait eu des
difficultés on en a parlé tout à l'heure
mais deuxième guerre mondiale à la
participer aux épreuves du peuple ça a
été reconnu elle a vécu avec ça ça lui a
donné une crédibilité que peut-être
comme on a dit maintenant les portes les
suivants vont devoir vont devoir gagner
pour eux-mêmes parce que c'est pas
évident pour l'instant c'est parce que
c'est parce qu'on a vu elle parlait peu
mais sa parole avait du poids
ne passait pas son temps à accorder les
entrevues ou à placotter comme on dit
elle était loin de la presse people et
même dans les grandes presque
jour dernier elle a jamais accordé
d'entrevue et c'est peut-être une
prudence quand on exerce un rôle comme
celui-là c'est toujours périlleux un
entrevue le prince Charles à certaines
époques si un peu cassé les dents vous
souvenez peut-être que c'est lointain
mais c'est vrai
il était un peu ridiculisé pour avoir
avoué ça alors elle gardait elle a
compris dès les années 60 quand ils ont
diffusé un documentaire sur la famille
royale qu'elle doit garder un certain
mystère et qu'elle ne doit pas se
disperser à tout tu vois elle parlait
peu sa parole avait du poids il y a une
bouteille qui dit elle faisait rien mais
elle le faisait bien
mais elle avait elle avait pas de
pouvoir politique mais elle avait quand
même un sens politique parce qu'elle a
quand même agi dans certains dossiers
même si elle le faisait pas très
ouvertement elle savait comme vous dites
faire passer ses messages et faire
comprendre un peu ou elle se situait sur
certains enjeux combien ça a dû être
difficile pour elle avec Margot qui
avait des vues totalement opposées et
qui on pourrait dire la prenait de où
la reine c'est beaucoup de choses on n'a
pas besoin de faire la leçon et suivant
les fuites il y en a malgré tout
elle lui faisait la leçon et la reine
trouvait ça très très variable mais de
déjà jamais en public dans les
représentations théâtrales qui ont été
faites de ça on voit ma gothatcher
arriver avec un journal comment ça vient
du palais vous avez dit qu'on s'entend
pas ça c'est peut-être pas passé de
manière aussi dramatique mais il y avait
mes ententes entre les deux et ça
devient très compliqué pour elle
un certain n'est pas bien avec tous les
premiers ministres je sais pas comment
ça s'est passé avec les nœuds d'ailleurs
il y a rien filtrer sauf que le dernier
juste un trou d'eau dit que c'est très
bien que c'est la personne je le cite
qu'il une des personnes qu'il aille
mieux apprécié dans sa vie alors
conseillé tout à fait là de grand-mère à
petit-fils ça a bien fonctionné mais
alors faudrait voir avec les autres
premiers ministres canadiens mais c'est
certain avec les les premiers ministres
qu'elle a eu la quinzaine qu'elle a eu
pendant son règne
aucune information ne filtrée de ces
rencontres hebdomadaires avec ces
premiers ministres même j'ai vu une
entrevue où on demandait
l'opinion de David Carmen sur justement
le décès de la reine et il a dit un
moment donné c'est venu que on a parlé
de ces rencontres de malheur et tout de
suite il a dit c'est une information qui
est privilégiée et ça s'arrête là alors
la reine savait que elle pouvait
vraiment donner son opinion à ses
premiers ministres et que ça s'arrêtait
là que ça n'allait pas plus loin ça veut
pas dire que les premiers ministres ont
fait exactement ce que elle leur
suggérait mon moins elle avait parce que
toute l'expérience qu'elle avait côté
politique de diplomatie tous les grands
qu'elle a rencontré que ça soit les
premiers ministres mais les présidentes
depuis 70 ans donc elle avait un bagage
incroyable
la connaissance sur ce qui était le
diplomatie internationale et elle était
prête à la partager cette information là
cette connaissance là avec ses premiers
ministres ce qu'ils en ont fait chacun y
a été à sa façon mais il reste que ça
aussi ça a été extrêmement
ça a eu une valeur incroyable pour la
façon que
le Royaume-Uni a aussi été dirigé par la
suite
d'État les chefs d'État venaient à
justement palais de Windsor pas c'est le
week-end avec la reine souvent c'est une
opportunité pour converser pour pour
être jouer le rôle on avait parlé plutôt
aussi un peu la confesseuse des grandes
Semoun pour entendre des choses de
confidentielles mais c'est quelque chose
qui lui a effectivement donné une une
expérience des affaires du monde mais
qu'il y a aussi donné une expérience de
soft spa qu'elle a certainement pu
exercer derrière la scène qu'on ne
connaîtra pas dans les prochains 70 ans
parce que tout ça ce sera
en confidentiel c'est aller jusqu'à
l'ouverture des archives bien après nous
malheureusement une personne qui peut
être assez simple et dans la confidence
notre ancienne console allez je dire
Michael Jean concert à Radio-Canada a
été comme vous savez gouverneur général
ils sont mariés est venu à la radio le
matin nous raconter que ils avaient été
reçu à Balmoral lui et elle et là avec
la reine les deux lavaient la vaisselle
il parlait de choses très très
ordinaires des choses du jour mais en
même temps là elle se livre de manière
très très familière et les gens peuvent
apprendre des choses bénéficier de sa
sagesse alors ceux qui ont eu accès à
elle en disent les plus grands éloges de
sa sagesse de son expérience de sa
simplicité et de son humour parfois son
humour mon dieu j'ai vu des images elle
va dans une école et les enfants 7 ans
ils disent
de leur expliquer mais pour ça tout le
temps je fais ça une fois de temps en
temps elle elle se mettait à leur niveau
pour leur expliquer ça alors il y a
cette blague qui circule dans de c'est
quoi la très proche collaborateurs qui
rencontrent les marchés ensemble je
pense que c'était à Windsor et elle un
touriste les accords c'est leur dire
est-ce que vous avez déjà vu la reine et
donc elle est à côté de lui et donc
c'est la personne le tourisme pose la
question à son collaborateur il répond
oui des fois je l'ai déjà côtoyé puis
comment elle est etc etc et la reine n'a
jamais branché elle a jamais rien dit et
finalement je pense que le tourisme
demande même à la reine de prendre la
photo avec cet homme qui a déjà côtoyé
la reine et elle était avait gardé tout
à fait son sang-froid mais là on vient
de d'assister donc à la fin de ce règne
je pense qu'on devra aussi c'est
possible on aimerait revoir un peu ces
images de la cérémonie quand justement
on vient on enlève la couronne l'orbe le
sceptre c'est c'est là qu'on se rend
compte on l'a qu'elle se détache de ce
c'est un grand un grand symbole on va
peut-être avoir ces images et ensuite
on va voir le cercueil donc qui descend
dans la crypte royale et ensuite
voilà le cercueil
un peu plus tôt donc on avait enlevé on
les voit derrière la couronne le sceptre
et l'orbe qui seront remis donc à
Charles au moment de son couronnement un
passage
d'un roi d'une reine au roi donc c'est
c'est ce sont sur ces images donc ce
sont que c'est terminé ce règne de 70
ans dans cette cérémonie un peu plus
intime que celle à laquelle on a assisté
ce matin à Westminster ou c'était
vraiment ces funérailles d'État alors
que là c'était des amis des proches de
la famille royale les représentants
aussi des pays du commonwealt dont elle
était toujours la souveraine qui était
présent le Premier ministre Justin
Trudeau y était donc et
visuellement c'est la fin de règne on
voit les dernières minutes de règne et
on parlera d'Elisabeth je pense que
comme dire chez la deuxième
ère elizabethen très longue et très
comment dirais-je très prolifique elle
était très présente puis elle a un peu
changé la dynamique la famille royale
alors c'est un règne important
dans la société en politique
technologique
et elle a su s'adapter quand même ça ça
a été sa force
[Musique]
alors ça c'était le cornemiseur de la
reine avait demandé à ce qu'il joue à
cette cérémonie
qui met un peu faim à tous et Thomas
assez funérailles à cette semaine et
plus c'est dix jours de deuil national
l'image forte qui dit tout ne la fin
d'un règne
ce départ
[Musique]
est donc révérend on veut vous remercier
là-dessus d'avoir passé ces longues
heures avec nous
[Musique]
on va poursuivre avec la cérémonie parce
qu'il y a une cérémonie comme hémorative
à Ottawa donc on va poursuivre avec ça
mais on vous libère et on vous remercie
de tout ce que de vos lumières de ce que
vous nous avez apporté merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
re-bonjour mesdames messieurs on
l'entame donc la dernière partie de
notre émission spéciale après Londres et
Windsor on a eu droit à des cérémonies
grandioses d'une ampleur jamais vu on va
se rendre maintenant à la cathédrale
Chris Church d'Ottawa aura lieu la
cérémonie commémorative du Canada à la
mémoire de la reine alors vous voyez ces
images qui nous parviennent en direct je
crois de la de la cathédrale Chrys
Church donc à Ottawa une parade vient de
commencer dans les rues de la capitale
composé notamment de membres des Forces
armées canadiennes et de la GRC une
salle de 96 coups de canon sera aussi
tiré pendant ce défilé à proximité de la
cathédrale un coup de canon par année de
vie de la reine bien sûr la reine qui
est décédée à 96 ans
donc ces images dans les rues d'Ottawa
de ce défiler défiler militaires avant
qui précède donc cette cérémonie
commémorative cérémonie commémorative à
la cathédrale
[Musique]
alors pendant que se déroule se défiler
militaire on va aller rejoindre notre
collègue Daniel Thibault qui est devant
la cathédrale touristique à Ottawa
Daniel c'est donc là que la cérémonie
aura lieu dans quelques minutes
voilà dans quelques minutes Céline déjà
une vaste majorité des gens qui ont été
conviés à la cérémonie aujourd'hui sont
arrivés dans le courant des dernières 45
minutes des membres du corps
diplomatique qui sont installés ici
Ottawa des représentants du gouvernement
canadien aussi une trentaine des
ministres du gouvernement Trudeau entre
autres le chef de l'opposition qui a
paulièvre le chef DNP des jogg meeting
doit être ici le juge en chef de la Cour
suprême monsieur et Monsieur Wagner
ministre conservateur est arrivé un peu
plus tôt aussi et d'une Clark Sun qui a
été gouverneur général également est
arrivé un peu plus tôt elle aussi des
gens qui sont arrivés ici pour venir
pour venir rendre hommage à la
souveraine pour venir rendre hommage à
la reine Élisabeth c'est particulier
parce que on confirmait ce matin que le
Canada est le seul pays du commonweal à
tenir une cérémonie commémorative
nationale de ce genre aujourd'hui j'ai
posé la question au ministre du
Patrimoine Pablo Rodriguez qui est celui
dont le ministère était responsable
d'organiser d'organiser la cérémonie
dites-moi le Canada ce que j'en
comprends et le seul pays du commonwald
à tenir une cérémonie comme celle-ci
pourquoi effectivement on le fait parce
que c'est important de prendre le temps
de
se rappeler de souvenirs de la remercier
aussi elle avait un attachement profond
pour le Canada pour les Canadiens et à
travers ses 70 années de règne elle
représenter
certaines stabilité à travers les bons
et les moments alors nous on est le plan
merci quel est le message que les
Canadiens que le gouvernement du Canada
veut envoyer à la famille royale quel
est le message quand qu'on doit voir la
marque de respect vous savez la reine
est venue au Canada 23 fois dans 22 fois
cette draine c'était assez beaucoup aux
questions de la réconciliation des
peuples autochtones donc une femme
encore une fois qui qui avait un amour
un attachement profond que canadien on
est là pour lui dire merci est-ce qu'on
tourne une certaine page aujourd'hui
ouais c'est toute une histoire 70 ans
pensez-y c'est la première fois à 70 ans
que l'on change
de manière donc maintenant c'est Charles
3 l'occasion de rencontrer pas longtemps
et lui aussi avait intérêt marqué pour
toutes les questions de la
réconciliation de l'environnement ainsi
de suite donc j'espère qu'on va se
diriger vers ça aussi pour vous
personnellement ça veut dire quoi être
ici aujourd'hui mais pour moi c'est de
me joindre aux autres pour encore une
fois pour la remercier puis souligner
son dévouement vous savez c'est pas
évident je sais que ça semble facile
d'une certaine façon tout ça oui il y a
tout ce qu'il entoure mais en même temps
c'est une vie publique 100% public là il
y a plus rien de privé les bons les
mauvais moments sont exposés au public
et c'est une vie donc de service qu'elle
a rendu pendant 70 ans
une vie de service 70 ans donc le Canada
veut dire merci et certains de ceux qui
sont à la cérémonie Daniel ont justement
des souvenirs assez personnels à
raconter à propos de la reine qui est
venu souvent donc ici
oui monsieur monsieur Rodriguez le
disait 23 fois 22 fois c'est à titre de
souveraine et il y a évidemment des
Canadiens qui ont eu l'occasion de
passer des moments peut-être un petit
peu plus personnel avec elle de la
connaître de connaître un autre côté de
la souveraine de la rencontrer dans
d'autres circonstances j'ai eu
l'occasion de m'entretenir avec deux
personnes que vous connaissez bien qui
ont eu l'occasion de rencontrer la reine
Elizabeth dans d'autres circonstances
que les moments très public très
protocolaires auxquels il se prête
normalement durant ces visites le
premier c'est Dominique Leblanc ministre
du Conseil des ministres de Monsieur
Trudeau mais dans le père Roméo Leblanc
a été gouverneur général et donc dans ce
contexte là monsieur Leblanc a eu
l'occasion de rencontrer la reine
Elizabeth de façon un peu plus
personnelle que vous allez l'entendre
Dominique Leblanc vous avez vous avez
une relation particulière avec la
famille royale vous avez une relation
particulière avec la souveraine vous
l'avez rencontré
j'aurais pas dit que j'ai une relation
particulière avec la famille royale j'ai
eu le privilège de rencontrer sa Majesté
à quelques reprises comme jeune adjoint
dans le cabinet de Monsieur chrétien à
l'époque dans les années 90 elle était
au jeu du corps manoir en Colombo
britannique mais c'est surtout dans les
années 90 où mon père était gouverneur
général qu'elle a demeuré à real hall
pendant quelques jours il y avait un
souper un soir un genre de barbecue
familial avec elle et son mari le duc
était d'embour on avait deux tables de 8
ça donnait que j'étais à la table avec
la reine et Monsieur chrétien qui était
alors Premier ministre et j'ai apprécié
énormément la conversation complètement
relax
détendue mais surtout la reine qui
parlait en français presque toute la
soirée à Monsieur chrétien à moi elle
posait des questions au Premier ministre
sur les enjeux du jour au Canada et à un
moment donné pour faire rire la reine
monsieur chrétien avait démontré le
fameux showwiniganhen shape quand il y
avait pris le manifestant par la gorge
elle lui avait posé la question à propos
de ça elle avait vu à la télévision
alors Monsieur chrétien voulait montrer
à la reine comment il avait fait ça et
puis c'est ma gorge qui est devenu le
prof pour pour montrer à la reine
comment il avait fait ça alors c'était
une soirée complètement mémorable et
relax détendu
le sourire
on peut imaginer pour lui pour le jeune
garçon enfin le jeune homme qu'il était
à ce moment-là il y avait une soirée il
y avait une soirée de libre dans
l'horaire et il m'a dit c'est la reine
qui a proposé mais pourquoi on fait pas
un barbecue et c'était littéralement
dans la cour intérieure de rideauxhal
deux tables de 8 comme ça sur le gazon
avec les cuisiniers de rideau qui peut
paraître barbecue une espèce de buvet de
buffet où les gens sont allés servir et
c'était un moment tout à fait normal et
il me disait c'était comme si vous étiez
assis à la table avec avec votre tente
en train de discuter tant que vous avez
pas vu depuis longtemps en train de
discuter de choses et d'autres très
naturel il en garde un excellent
souvenir un autre qui regarde aussi qui
garde aussi un bon souvenir de sa
rencontre avec la reine avec la reine
Elizabeth c'est Pierre Paulus le
conservateur le nouveau lieu de canon
derrière vous Daniel ouais d'ailleurs
vous allez en entendre comme ça
13 pour chaque année de vie de la
souveraine ça a commencé il y a
maintenant une minute et demie et ça
devrait durer une quinzaine de minutes
ça fait partie du programme du défilé
donc normalement ça devait commencer au
moment où le cortège se rendait sur la
rue Wellington à quelques ingés de
Pierre d'ici ils doivent donc être en
route là au moment où l'on se parle
alors je vous disais donc pierre Paulus
qui est qui est le lieutenant québécois
le nouveau lieutenant québécois du chef
de l'opposition officielle pierre
poirievre qui a été élu à la tête du
Parti conservateur il y a un peu plus
d'une semaine maintenant décidément
monsieur polyèvre est arrivé un peu plus
tôt job meeting aussi le juge en chef
d'Aqua suprême Richard Wagner puis la
police donc qui l'a rencontré lorsqu'il
était militaire il garde un excellent
souvenir de la rencontre voici ce que ça
donne
dites-moi vous avez rencontré la reine
je crois ouais absolument en 2006
lorsque j'étais commandant du richement
la chaudière j'ai eu la chance d'être
seul audience privée parce majesté et
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui c'est ça
signifie quelque chose de spécial
également pour moi à titre personnel en
plus d'être là aujourd'hui comme député
pour représenter les citoyens qui qui
pense à sa majesté le fait personnel est
bien là comment comment c'était comment
il y a peu de gens qui ont eu l'occasion
quand même d'avoir ce moment-là comment
c'était c'était un moment qui mémorable
par le fait que Sa Majesté a tout fait
pour nous rendre premièrement très à
l'aise parce qu'il faut s'entendre que
c'est un peu stressant de se présenter
là puis premièrement dans un français
excellent ils ont mis à l'aise sur le
fait de certaines blagues pour démontrer
que finalement c'était une femme une
humaine tout était quelqu'un qui était
normal dans son rôle qui était
majestueux mais dans sa personnalité
elle voulait que les gens soient bien
puis on a eu une vingtaine de minutes
d'audience que je me suis mis toute ma
vie
alors c'est ça quand les gens l'ont eu
la chance de la rencontrer ils se
gardent tous cette espèce de souvenirs
assez
inoubliable de cette rencontre avec elle
qui apparemment se concentrait vraiment
sur les gens à qui elle parlait que les
gens à qui elle rencontrait donc là
encore en français
dans un français impeccable et tous tous
les gens qui l'ont rencontré me l'ont
souligné à maintes reprises dans un elle
faisait un effort particulier Dominique
Blanc me disait tout à l'heure la
conversation tout le long du souper
s'est déroulé pratiquement uniquement en
français langue qu'elle maîtrisait
extrêmement bien motivé et elle
s'assurait de l'utiliser justement pour
que les gens autour d'elle se sent à
l'aise et ça faisait probablement une
grande différence alors le nouveau roi
parle lui aussi un excellent français
paraît-il donc parlez-nous un peu de
cette cérémonie qui est prévue à 13h
Daniel donc à la cathédrale qui est la
cathédrale la cathédrale anglicane de la
capitale
voilà quand la cathédrale américaine de
la cathédrale c'est ici que l'on a tenu
également
la cérémonie que mémorative pour
souligner le décès du prince Philippe
il y a des gens un peu plus d'un an
maintenant et donc c'est ICI que ça se
déroule c'est la tête c'est c'est
l'Église c'est c'est le siège de
l'église handicap au Canada cérémonie
évidemment qui sera
multi confessionnelle parce que l'on
veut refléter ce côté-là très
particulier du Canada on veut s'assurer
que les éléments de la cérémonie
reflètent la vie de la reine Elizabeth
et vous entendrez entre autres durant la
cérémonie des hommages rendus par l'ex
gouverneur général et
l'ex Premier ministre Brian ma journée
et des prestations également prestations
musicales de Ginette Reno qui
interprétera ceux qui s'en vont et de
refus train right qui lui interprétera
la chanson Hallelujah ça sera au menu de
la cérémonie commémorative nationale qui
commencera dans quelques minutes 13
heures c'est ça
à 13h normalement ça devait en fait on
arrivait la cérémonie ici en fonction de
l'horaire en Grande-Bretagne je sais pas
si le petit retard qu'on a connu en
Grande-Bretagne aura un impact sur le
cérémonie ici possiblement c'est de
recommencer l'année prochaine
avec vous bien sûr merci beaucoup Daniel
merci
et voilà Valérie Michaela
elle qui suit la parade donc a commencé
à quelques minutes
dites-nous comment ça se passe quel est
l'ambiance l'état d'esprit autour de
vous c'est assez tranquille en ce moment
Céline on peut entendre ou loin arriver
la parade qui a commencé à 12h10 au
Manège militaire place quartier c'est
une marche de deux points 2 km marche
qui est ouverte par des membres de la
GRC à chevaux vous pouvez peut-être les
voir derrière moi les entendre ils sont
suivis de 100 membres des Forces armées
canadiennes et des membres de la
formation musicale des portes drapeaux
aussi la marche est aussi fermée par des
membres de la GRC à chevaux petit
changement de plan il devait y avoir un
défilé aérien des CF18 qui devait
survoler le ciel d'Ottawa
malheureusement ça a été annulé en
raison de la météo mais vous avez pu le
mentionner aussi à Daniel les 96 salves
de canons qu'on a entendu pour les 96
ans de la reine en ce moment il fait pas
très beau à ta voix il y a à peine une
heure il y avait très peu de gens ici
même que c'était vide mais il y a
quelques personnes qui se sont
rassemblées le long de ce parcours là on
a parlé à quelques-unes d'entre elles
leurs impressions sur cet événement là
et pourquoi elles sont ici
particulièrement des francophones aussi
on peut les écouter
oui c'est parce que je pense quand même
ça fait partie de l'histoire même si
même si qu'on est francophone on vit
quand même parmi un milieu où la reine
est importante francophone
la reine a toujours été là quand même et
puis la gouverneur général on a ça au
Canada ça fait partie de notre histoire
aussi j'étais un peu abaisse
de chance ici
je repensé qu'on aurait eu de la
difficulté à se mettre en ligne
alors vous voyez le la parade qui passe
derrière moi qui va se rendre jusqu'à la
cathédrale Grace Church c'est le point
final de cette parade pour aujourd'hui
très bien merci beaucoup Valérie au
revoir
alors je retrouve nos invités sur le
plateau Marc Estelle qui sont avec nous
depuis ce matin et l'ancien sénateur
Serge royal qui s'est joint à nous
bonjour Monsieur Joël bonjour madame
Galipeau
vous êtes un admirateur de la monarchie
je crois est-ce qu'on peut vous appeler
comme ça j'ai toujours essayé de
comprendre le fonctionnement de
l'institution parce que c'est très
facile de dire ça c'est le passé on est
ailleurs des institutions sont
d'aujourd'hui sont plus simples plus
facile d'accès pour tout le monde alors
cette idée que nous avons une succession
de monarque depuis le régime français en
fait depuis François 1er le Canada est
peut-être la plus ancienne démocratie au
monde être demeurer une monarchie
constitutionnelle depuis 1534 mise à
part évidemment la Grande-Bretagne
nécessairement alors on a eu une
succession
763 et on a eu ensuite une succession de
monarque britanniques et le Canada
évolué jusqu'à sa plaine souveraineté et
je voudrais dire un rôle international
complètement autonome depuis finalement
l'accession de la reine Élisabeth II au
trône en 1952 donc il y a eu une
évolution constante du Canada sur chacun
des monarques sous lequel le Canada
continue de se développer et ça mon avis
c'est important de le comprendre pour
voir comment les institutions les lois
les conventions ce qui nous régit a
évoluer depuis François 1er depuis 1534
alors on a une histoire qui est
finalement très longue dans notre lien
avec la monarchie française la monarchie
britannique et depuis la reine Elizabeth
II la monarchie canadienne puisque elle
est reine du Canada c'est à ce titre là
que ces funérailles ont lieu aujourd'hui
au de ce commémorer
sa disparition ici même à Ottawa oui je
crois que c'était essentiel parce
qu'elle porte le titre de reine du
Canada c'est un peu si je puis faire une
image et là elle a deux couronnes elle a
la Couronne britannique qu'elle porte et
qu'on voit évidemment ce qu'on a vu sur
le cercueil et ensuite elle a une
couronne canadienne et quand elle agit
au nom du Canada elle agit avec la
couronne canadienne a-t-elle enseigne
que parfois les deux couronnes sont en
conflit par exemple dans le cas de
la décolonisation par exemple de
l'Afrique du Sud la Couronne britannique
qui était avisée par Madame Thatcher
rite riches sentent demander évidemment
le relâchement d'un Nelson Mandela mais
la couronne canadienne conseillée par
Brian mélroni elle était favorable alors
quand elle agit au nom du Canada elle
agit en parfaite autonomie par rapport à
la Grande-Bretagne
reprenons un exemple encore plus récent
la guerre en Irak comme reine du
Royaume-Uni elle a déclaré la guerre en
Irak mais comme reine du Canada elle a
été avisée à l'époque par Monsieur
chrétien de ne pas déclarer la guerre en
Irak alors comme personnalité qui
possède deux couronnes elle agit selon
des conseils qui peuvent parfois être en
conflit et c'est ce qu'il faut essayer
de comprendre dans l'institution et mes
efforts pour revenir à votre question
ont toujours été avant de dire on va
tout refaire essayons donc de comprendre
comment ce principe a évolué dans nos
lois dans notre Constitution et comment
on peut continuer de développer notre
liberté comme un des pays les plus
égalitaires au monde et ça c'est un
élément quand même important de la
réalité avec laquelle on est on a à
gérer le pays
dans les rues d'Ottawa et se dirige vers
l'église Chrysler chez aura lieu donc
cette cérémonie commémorative mais on va
on va on va vous inclure dans la
conversation parce qu'évidemment avec la
disparition de la reine est-ce que
maintenant toute cette question qu'on a
peut-être repoussée sur l'avenir de la
monarchie au Canada se pose à nouveau
s'accélère même dans plusieurs pays du
commonweil les relations des pays avec
la monarchie sont différentes sont
distinctes nous avons comme je l'ai
mentionné tantôt nous avons une relation
coloniale avec la monarchie française
jusqu'en 1763 et cette relation
coloniale d'une certaine façon elle est
rappelée sur le drapeau du Québec le
drapeau du Québec il y a quatre fleurs
de lys d'où elles viennent ces quatre
fleurs de l'islam elles viennent de
notre héritage de la monarchie française
alors on a beau dire qu'aujourd'hui on
veut être complètement
autonome sur le plan du chef de il y en
demeure pas moins que il y a encore dans
notre réalité et singulièrement au
Québec une réalité de monarchie un
principe monarchique qui démon que
depuis le début de notre existence comme
colon sur ce territoire qui était déjà
occupé par des autochtones qui exercent
des jeunes souveraineté sur le
territoire il y a un lien qui est très
particulier que aucun autre pays du
commonwear n'a pas alors avant de
repenser ce lien-là comme je vous
saoulais il faut comprendre l'histoire
d'où nous venons et ça mon avis c'est
essentiel pour comment dirais demeurer
rationnel dans la construction de
l'édifice du système politique qui nous
gère et sous lequel notre liberté
s'exerce
il est vrai comme dit Monsieur Royal
que depuis 1939 qu'on peut voir un roi
en personne George aussi a été le
premier roi régnant à débarquer sur
notre territoire
sa successeur en fait Élisabeth duel et
même ni avec la télévision et on le vit
aujourd'hui son décès a été marqué par
la télévision c'est une évolution la
reine est beaucoup plus présente chez
nous Victoria c'est une inconnue pour
nous elle était même pour les sujets
britanniques
il décède du Prince Albert elle s'est
retirée complètement de toute la vie
publique a-t-elle enseigne que le
premier ministre pile à un moment donné
est allé la voir puis le dit Majesté il
faut que vous vous montriez en public
parce que les sujets commencent à se
détacher de vous et on entend les
critiques parce que vous êtes
complètement absente et on a
l'impression que vous avez abandonné
votre rôle
la reine s'est rendue à la vie de son
premier ministre et elle a commencé à se
réintégrer dans des apparitions
publiques mais c'est probablement la
reine qui était
indépendamment de la longue durée de son
règne qui était la moins vue en personne
parmi ces sujets évidemment il y avait
la photographie il y avait les portraits
qui circulaient en quantité j'ai presque
industriel parce que la presse est
énormément développée pendant son règne
après se développer au milieu du 19e
siècle et la reine est devenue présente
par l'image mais comme personne physique
les gens ne la voyaient très peu elle se
présentait très peu dans des activités
publiques
mais quand on compare avec ce qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure en Grande-Bretagne
qu'est-ce que ça peut dire qu'est-ce que
ça nous dit sur l'attachement peut-être
des des Canadiens Estelle c'est que
évidemment au Canada
la différence est très marquée
les Canadiens il y en a plusieurs qui
voudraient s'en détacher
là on le voit c'est une cérémonie qui
sobre mais les gens sont pas certains si
ils voudraient vraiment voir se
poursuivre et le nombre de personnes qui
assistent à la cérémonie c'est vraiment
bon de ne pas c'est peut-être pour le
spectacle mais ça reste que il y a très
très peu de gens ça serait intéressant
de savoir si les livres de condoléances
qui ont été ouverts ont été vraiment
rempli de signature et qui ont eu qu'ils
ont dû en faire un mètre d'autres mais
je crains que ici c'est très très
différent la perception que les gens ont
de la maladie elle est elle est présente
mais en même temps comme elle ne
résidait pas au Canada c'est c'est
éloignement là qui fait que aujourd'hui
les gens sont
différents mais presque on trouve les
deux extrêmes qui vous permettez
sur la collection de la colline
parlementaire elle était auventionnée la
colline parlementaire était entière de
rouge pour accueillir Elisabeth sur le
règne de Monsieur
[Musique]
tout à l'heure je voulais souligner
qu'il y a eu une autre extrême qui en 64
au moment où des indépendantistes à
Québec était pas d'accord que Jean Le
Sage invite la souveraine à venir il y a
eu une émeute littéralement
Bourgault arrêté ce pire beaucoup arrêté
ça un peu à la dernière minute mais ça
failli dégénérer effectivement ça
partiellement de générer on appelait ça
le samedi de la matraque on a fait des
arrestations de gens qui étaient sur
place et puis il y avait des affiches
bébêtes retourne chez vous alors c'était
très hostile alors on assit entre les
deux extrêmes je pense qu'une
distinction entre les deux parce que
ce que Madame dit mentionne c'est que
cette espèce si vous voulez
d'éloignement de la monarchie cet aspect
d'éloignement l'égard des institutions
regardez quand le pape François est venu
à Québec à Sainte-Anne de Beaupré on
croyait qu'il y aurait 100000 personnes
et finalement il y a eu les autochtones
ou à peu près bon quelques centaines de
d'autres personnes et on a déploré
précisément et le pape lui-même l'a dit
que l'on s'éloigne de l'institution de
l'église au Québec alors je pense que
cette idée d'identification à
l'institution et beaucoup moins présent
dans le José dire dans la vie courante
aujourd'hui au Canada au Québec que elle
ne l'était il y a quelques années par
ailleurs il y a des éléments aussi
importants on se dit est-ce que c'est
nécessaire cette institution là est-ce
qu'on en a vraiment besoin comme dirait
un de vos collègues monsieur maxwin
établi régulièrement en posant cette
question là est-ce qu'on en a encore
besoin je crois que avant de dire on en
a plus besoin on devrait se demander ça
sert à quoi alors
elle est jamais vraiment abordée parce
que on prend pour acquis que comme je
vous l'ai mentionné que ça ne sert à
rien et puis quand il y a des gens qui
pensent qu'on envoie de l'argent en
Bretagne puis qui vivent à nos dépenses
etc il y a toutes sortes de rumeurs de
canards qui si qui vole autour de
l'instruction mais elle n'est jamais
vraiment expliquée au fond et on ne
comprend jamais vraiment que sont les
éléments essentiels que ça apporte à la
stabilité de l'état et ça à mon avis
c'est un des éléments essentiels qui
maintiennent le haut niveau de
démocratie parlementaire à l'intérieur
duquel nous évoluons comme système
originaire de Westminster qu'on appelle
le système de Westminster mais ce
système là il propose essentiellement
sur le principe de d'une existence d'un
souverain et ça les gens ne comprennent
pas ils s'imaginent que la démocratie
c'est seulement délire des députés et
puis à Ottawa Québec ou délire en mer ou
des conseillers et puis là il nous parle
à notre nom puis gère les affaires à
notre nom la réalité de l'existence d'un
état et beaucoup plus complexe regardez
les États-Unis on a toujours pensé que
les États-Unis c'est le pays plus
démocratique au monde mais le pays qui
ont eu un invasion de son parlement est
presque renversement du pouvoir ce lieu
au mois de janvier l'an dernier chez les
Américains qui est une des plus vieilles
démocraties au monde alors et pourquoi
parce qu'il y avait un président qui est
indifférent à l'idée qu'il fallait
maintenir la règle de droit dans le
système parlementaire américain alors
tout ça ça n'arrive pas de rien ça veut
dire que les institutions doivent avoir
une certaine stabilité
elles doivent opérer au bénéfice de la
liberté des citoyens et ce principe de
stabilité là dans un système anarchique
qui s'appuie sur le fait qu'il y a à la
tête de l'État une personne qui est pas
susceptible d'être influencé à droite à
gauche de prendre position sur des
questions controversées de déterminer
que le niveau d'immigration est pas
assez élevé trop élevé de dire que si on
veut être liker qui font une vie ce
signe là où cet autre là la personne qui
est à la tête de l'État ne se mêle pas
des questions controversées elles s'en
remet en gouvernement qui lui est là
pour un certain nombre de temps
déterminés par les électeurs alors le
principe de stabilité c'est le principe
monarchique et ça il faut une comprendre
avant de dire bon on va tout le monde
balayer ça par le support et puis on va
recommencer
alors je veux juste dire que c'est quand
même on attend une cérémonie qui doit
commencer dans quelques minutes cours de
laquelle l'ancien premier va prononcer
un des discours et Daniel Thibault c'est
toujours devant la cathédrale crash
Ottawa avec le chef du NPD joke meeting
donc on vous écoute Daniel
voilà Céline de Jack meeting le chef
d'une [ __ ] qui est arrivé ici il y a
quelques minutes après monsieur signe
pourquoi c'est important qu'est-ce que
ça représente cette cérémonie pour vous
aujourd'hui je pense pour plusieurs
personnes à travers les pays la reine
représente la sole ménage qu'ils ont
connu toute leur vie une symbole de
stabilité mais aussi les gens étaient
impressionnés par
sa service et comment elle s'engager
toute sa vie de toujours fait son devoir
pour le service même dans les jours
finales de sa vie elle était là pour
installer le nouveau Premier ministre en
Royaume-Uni donc c'est quelque chose qui
est le Canadiens sont vraiment
impressionner pas qu'est-ce qu'elle
représente pour vous la reine Elizabeth
personnellement comment vous avez perçu
la souveraine je reconnaissent comment
elle a joué une rôle de service et de
stabilité pour plus de personnes et je
suis quelqu'un qui est aussi reconnaître
qu'elle était une mère une grande mère
et une pilier pour sa famille est-ce que
est-ce que on tourne la page est-ce que
c'est un moment où on tourne la page
aujourd'hui est-ce que il y en a
plusieurs qui sont mis à parler de
remise en question du lien entre le
Canada la monarchie vous voyez ça
comment je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est
une journée pour réfléchir sur la vie de
la reine Elizabeth mais c'est une
conversation je pense importante pour
l'avenir et il y a un défi maintenant
pour le nouveau foie le roi Charles pour
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire avec son
plateforme maintenant il a déjà
mentionné qu'il reconnaitre l'impact
négatif de la mamachie sur la communauté
autochtone et sous les autres régions à
travers les pays je pense que c'était
une bonne finale et qu'est-ce qu'il va
faire avec cette plateforme de continuer
le travail important de reconnaître que
les impacts négatifs de la manachim
aussi la
c'est important aussi qui a mentionné
lors de sa dernière visite d'ailleurs
jogging merci infiniment merci merci
beaucoup voilà Céline le chef du NPD
jugmetzing qui fait partie des convives
des gens qui sont à la cérémonie 600
personnes qui ont été invitées des
politiciens des dignitaires des membres
du corps diplomatique et au moment où je
vous parle on entend le cortège on
attend défilé qui arrive donc de plus en
plus près les 96 coups de canon ont été
se sont terminés il y a quelques minutes
on devrait donc voir arriver le cortège
ici dans les prochaines minutes et c'est
ce qui marquera le début de la CM1 ça
devait être à 13h aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il y aura un peu de retard
[Musique]
merci Daniel très bien et on va
rejoindre Louis-Philippe parce que des
artistes canadiens québécois vont rendre
hommage à la reine à Ottawa vous savez
déjà ce qu'on va nous présenter durant
cet événement Louis Philippe très
content de vous retrouver pour vous
parler justement de cette cérémonie
commémorative pour rendre hommage à la
reine Elizabeth II c'est le vrai
commencer dans quelques minutes
justement la cathédrale
oui au menu plusieurs îles bien entendu
des champs des prières aussi mettons un
peu de contexte dans tout ça si vous le
voulez bien Céline parce que tout
d'abord on va entendre un Amazing Grace
pièces musicales composées au 18e siècle
très importante pourquoi parce que
certaines paroles viennent proviennent
du Nouveau Testament c'est une pièce qui
est interprétée à maintes reprises au
cours des siècles dernier en Angleterre
par la suite on va entendre aussi le
poète anglophone officiel d'Ottawa et
qui sera là Albert Dumont et ça va être
l'occasion de voir et d'entendre des
artistes canadiens de renommer
internationales oui compense à Thomson
highway
interpréter à maintes reprises cette
chanson là et il nous a fait une des
plus belles interprétations je vous
dirai alléluia de leader de Cohen
chanson fleuve extraordinaire ce que je
vous propose pour vous donner peut-être
un avant-goût de ce qui va se passer
lors de cette cérémonie commémorative
c'est d'entendre le Night la chanter en
2017 lors de Montréal symphonique
[Musique]
de parfum
ouais Louis-Philippe donc une cérémonie
avec des moments musicaux très forts en
tout cas on s'attend à ce que ce soit
très fort et quelles autres hommages on
va lui rendre son chanteuse d'origine
ontarienne va interpréter l'hymne
national le haut Canada qui me chassume
qu'on peut entendre sur environ 500
albums donc je suis très connu et vous
le voyez sur ces images la cérémonie qui
devrait débuter après l'arrivée de la
parade militaire et après l'arrivée de
tous ces dignitaires donc ce qu'on nous
dit c'est que c'est une cérémonie
d'environ 60 à 75 minutes vous le savez
Céline avec tous ces artistes qui sont
présents sur une horreur qui pourrait
fluctuer et son spectacle qui pourrait
être un peu plus long très bien merci
nous en avoir donné un avant-goût merci
Louis-Philippe
alors on va poursuivre cette discussion
même si je veux pas seulement qu'on
parle de l'avenir de la monarchie on va
parler aussi de vos rencontres avec la
reine et tout ça marque
du patrimoine dire et ben voilà c'est
pour montrer qu'on est Canadiens sont
attachés à la monarchie mais il y a
aussi que cette monarchie est remise en
question les sondages montrent que ce
soit les léger ou à la grandeur du
Canada les anges read la monarchie au
Canada est remise en question et pour
souscrire je souscrit tout à fait à
l'idée d'un serjoyal que ça prend un
personnage indépendant au-dessus de la
mêlée qui en quelque sorte fait les
actes protocolaires qui assure la
continuité de l'État j'admets que tout
ça est très important mais ce que de
plus en plus de gens croient c'est que
s'il s'agit d'une reine qui était à
l'extérieur il y a une dimension
coloniale dedans et des gens voudraient
trouver une autre façon nommée par
exemple quelqu'un qui est reçu l'Ordre
du Canada ou un personnage indépendant
je recommande on en trouve et
prestigieux plusieurs pays ont un
président indépendant c'est le cas
d'Israël d'autres pays aussi qui ont
envoyé justement leur président ou
funérailles d'Elisabeth II de manière à
assurer que notre présentant ou notre
chef de l'État il y aura un chef de
gouvernement Premier ministre et un chef
de l'État que ce chef de l'État soit
indépendant au-dessus de la Maëlle mais
neiman pas d'une situation coloniale
c'est ça l'argumentaire c'est ça que
en musique
et on revient
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette cérémonie est commémorative qui
est sur le point de commencer dans
quelques instants cérémonie qui devrait
durer une heure environ et où seront
présentés plusieurs moments musicaux on
en a parlé tout à l'heure avec
Louis-Philippe donc on va poursuivre
cette discussion sur sur la monarchie
sur l'avenir de la monarchie évidemment
je crois qu'il y a une nuance que je
voudrais porter à propos de Monsieur
Laurendeau monsieur landau dit nous
avons un souvenir colonial je m'excuse
mais depuis
1953 nous n'avons plus de liens colonial
avec la Grande-Bretagne parce depuis
1973 depuis l'arrivée au trône de la
reine Elizabeth II la reine porte le
titre de reine du Canada comme je l'ai
de mentionné tantôt donc elle est cette
institution monarchique est totalement
séparé de son rôle de reine du
Royaume-Uni et des autres territoires
dont elle est également la souveraine
qui sont membres du commonwalt et à
titre de règne du Canada elle ne
représente pas un lien colonial elle est
assume la totalité de la souveraineté
canadienne comme Rennes canadienne et
c'est ça qui est difficile à comprendre
pour la moyenne des gens et ce n'est pas
parce que la monarchie associée au
colonialisme regardez le roi de le roi
de Hollande bon les Pays-Bas ont été un
pays colonial ils ont eu des colonies
c'était une des puissances commerciales
du 7e siècle le pays européen plus riche
c'était des Pays-Bas un tout petit pays
de rien du tout qui avait des colonies
les Hollandais les Néerlandais dis-je ne
disent pas aujourd'hui ah nous avons eu
un passé colonial avec avec la monarchie
par conséquent nous sommes un pays
démocratique moderne nous allons couper
éolien nous allons abolir la monarchie
au Pays-Bas les trois pays de
Scandinavie sont des monarchies
également des sociétés exemplaires à
tout point de vue sur le plan social
alors la monarchie n'est pas
incompatible avec la liberté on va
regarder cette cérémonie
sont souvent des systèmes démocratique
il ne reste pas moins qu'avoir un
monarque qui vit à l'extérieur c'est ça
que les gens sentent là et puis dans
l'historique il faut pas oublier
l'historique dans l'historique et malgré
tout colonial mais les gens ressentir
disent ben moi ça me rassemble pas et
nous avons de plus en plus de Canadiens
d'autres origines et qui ont un mauvais
souvenir de cette monarchie et c'est
pour ça que c'est remis en question
progressivement d'année en année plus on
ne des Canadiens qui viennent d'ailleurs
pays du commonweather où il y a ce
ressentiment un peu et cette remise en
question on va regarder cette cérémonie
on va poursuivre la discussion tout de
suite après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut
[Musique]
bienvenue
dans la grâce et nous bénir de sa paix
de son lit de mort une jeune reine
vibrante s'est élevée et elle s'est
rendue auprès d'un cavalier il attendait
pour que il puisse se rendre au
loclement pour réfléchir à ses amis de
règne et dans le monde spirituel
où les vieux sont jeunes à nouveau la
reine et le duc
se sont retrouvés pour continuer cet
amour inconditionnel et tout ce qu'ils
se sont offerts tout pendant qu'ils
amenaient la culture il identité au
peuple britannique la mort physique
l'âme laisse-la derrière de le passer et
le cœur incroyable de l'esprit commence
donc sa vie éternelle
un nouveau monde s'entame où les justes
et les bons parmi nous
vont entendre une chanson à leur honneur
après la transformation du monde
physique au monde spirituel
la reine est morte
et dans cette terre de l'érable rouge la
tristesse remplit les cieux les larmes
les prières de ces animateurs s'envolent
comme les outardes à l'automne comme au
printemps en se rendant à la reine mère
qui atteint des trains de sa fille à
nouveau
aux gens endeuillés la reine n'était
comme ce grand arbre dans une arme
millénaire un arbre dans la grâce et
l'esprit
propagait la fierté l'orgueil à 10 km à
la ronde un arbre une mère pour tout un
chacun dans Le Devoir à amener le
bien-être ceux qui se protégeaient à
l'ombre de ses branches dans ce monde
brisé
où l'aigle regarde au nom du créateur où
il peut redresser les torts et
il peut nous atténuer la douleur de nos
disparus nous acceptons tous et toutes
que parfois nous allons être un [ __ ]
de gestes inappropriés que nous aurions
posé sur cette belle planète les
horreurs commis contre les peuples
autochtones des terres colonisés par les
Britanniques par les rois du passé et
bien
abordés autour du feu dans le monde des
esprits la reine à ce moment-là va donc
renoncer la brutalité du passé son bon
cœur les enseignements de cette nouvelle
lune qu'il a vu naître la lune de la
poissonnerie blanche ou on l'a vu
disparaître pour également l'instruire
sa capacité à se connecter avec les gens
ordinaires sont désir de rendre le monde
plus propre et plus sûr c'est des
vérités qu'elle porte qu'elle emporte
avec elle dans ce grand monde et des
hommes elle était une lumière pour ces
sujets britanniques pendant qu'elle
foulait le sol de cette terre
pour les gens qui l'aiment elle continue
d'être un feu qui offre maintenant dans
son cercle un modèle à suivre pour les
générations à venir pour que ces lignes
puissent à suivre plus elle reposer en
paix
Dieu de toutes les consolations
dans ton amour éternel et dans ta
miséricorde tu transformes les ténèbres
de la mort dans l'aube d'une nouvelle
vie
elle est venue des ténèbres de la
douleur et du chagrin vers la lumière et
vers la paix et la sérénité de la
présence
offre nous la grâce pour que nous
puissions
recommander l'âme de notre feu
souveraine à ton amour éternel
cet amour qui l'a soutenu dans cette vie
reçoit loi dans les armes de dans les
bras de ta miséricorde et rappelle-toi
selon la faveur que tu décernes à ton
peuple car à toi toutes les bénédictions
et tout honneur est dû aujourd'hui et
pour les siècles des siècles Amen
lecture de la lettre de saint Paul
apôtre aux Philippiens
soyez toujours dans la joie du Seigneur
je le redis et je le redis encore soyez
dans la joie que votre bienveillance et
vos gentillesse soient connues de tous
les hommes et de toutes les femmes le
Seigneur est proche ne soyez inquiet de
rien mais en toute circonstances priez
et supplié tout en rendant grâce pour
faire connaître à Dieu vos demandes
elle a paix de Dieu qui dépasse tous
qu'on peut concevoir gardera vos cœurs
et vos pensées dans le Christ de Jésus
enfin mes frères tous ceux qui est vrai
et noble
tous ceux qui est juste et pure
tous ceux qui dingue d'être aimé et en
heure et
tous ceux qui s'appellent vertus et qui
méritent des éloges
tout cela prenez le en compte
ce que vous avez appris et reçu
ce que vous avez vu et entendu de moi
mettez le en pratique
et le dieu de la paix sera avec vous
paroles de Seigneur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la reine 2 reine du Canada a toujours
souligné l'importance de la diversité
religieuse et de l'harmonie
multiconfessionnelle non ces messages à
l'intention du commonwei prenons ce
moment de réflexion tous ensemble
consacrer sa vie au service et au
bien-être de tous
de te confions Sa Majesté le Roi qui
pleure la perte de sa mère et tous les
membres de la famille royale endeuillées
nous prions pour les dirigeants de ce
monde afin qu'ils poursuivent la vision
d'Elizabeth II en conséquant leur vie au
bien commun
nous nous souvenons du service
d'Elisabeth II et de son dévouement à la
cause de la paix nous prions afin que
règne un esprit de respect et de
réconciliation entre les nations et les
peuples
nous prions également pour tous les
membres en uniformes qui servent sur
l'autorité du roi
protège la
protège-les afin qu'il puisse accomplir
leur devoir avec courage et persévérance
dans le respect de la dignité de chaque
être humain
l'avenga meilleur lieu d'amour puisse
l'engagement durable de la reine fait
écho dans nos vies afin que nous nous
engageons à vivre en paix les uns avec
les autres AMEN
[Musique]
ce
qui
nous sauver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis allé à l'Assemblée et on a dit
que le gouverneur général du Canada
massé Allen nous adresser la parole
arrivé
cette plateforme et on dit il nous a
annoncé que le roi était mort et que
nous avions aujourd'hui une reine
pour la première fois nous avons chanté
god save the queen que Dieu sauve la
reine ensuite il a expliqué que le
Canada reconnaît la reine comme sa
souveraine que la couronne canadienne
était la base de notre démocratie
constitutionnelle
comme je n'étais arrivé devant
auparavant quand j'avais trois ans en
tant que chinoise réfugiés venu d'une
région défaite de l'Empire britannique
qui s'appelait Hong Kong
que 48 ans plus tard je récupérerai la
fonction qui assumée monsieur Marcy
mais je dois Canada est un lieu
remarquable un lieu étonnant
il se passe des choses ici non seulement
pour moi mais pour des millions des
réfugiés et des migrants qui viennent
ici
pendant 70 ans la reine en tant
qu'incardation de la Couronne a été le
symbole de la légitimité démocratique
ce parmi nous qui respectons le modèle
de démocratie parlementaire de
Westminster nous avons à quel point
l'évolution de notre démocratie à
figurer au cœur de notre croissance en
tant que peuple canadien
dans la bibliothèque du château de
Windsor quand on a célébré le jubilé
d'or
2002 la reine m'a rejointain alors que
j'étais seul debout en train de regarder
une chemise blanche dans un casier de
verre
c'était la chemise de Charles 1 qu'il
portait quand il s'est fait guillotiner
elle a dit
dans une voix rock il était mon ancêtre
et ensuite elle est repartie pour
rejoindre le reste de la congrégation
aujourd'hui nous célébrons la reine dans
ce même palais de Westminster ou le
Charles 1er a été jugé et où ça t'a été
affichée pendant 20 ans
du consensus et de la justice et pendant
toute l'histoire de notre pays nous
avons avancé en bandissant ou en chanson
en courant ou en flânant pour traverser
une forêt d'ignorance de haine ou d'un
tolérance
et pourtant nous avons réussi à tracer
un chemin vers une clairière vers un
lieu lumineux qui ne font pas se faire
d'illusion
ne peut rester lumineux que si nous
l'entretenons si nous convenons de
l'agrandir si nous nous engageons et
nous promettons les uns aux autres que
l'effort en vaut la peine
si nous échouons là cette forêt va nous
étouffer et l'obscurité va tomber sur
nous et nous enverrai
pendant les 70 ans de cette ère
elisabethem chez nous avons en tant que
canadienne et canadien tu sais un
canevas nouveau grâce aux éléments
hérités de la Magnan
charte des libertés de 1215 quand le
peuple les gens ordinaires comme vous et
ont reçu du roi John la promesse d'une
véritable protection contre les
injustices
et Ninet en 1982 la reine Elizabeth II
a signé le rapatriement de notre
Constitution les Canadiens ont travaillé
à ce projet pendant des décennies on a
développé notre charte des droits et ses
libertés et les Canadiens se
rappelleront toujours de la reine comme
celle qui nous a rendu ce qui était à
nous nos droits humains nos libertés
dans cette forêt et il nous protège
contre les
les voies divisibles
ensuite
quand on a
fait un dîner
au vu dehors pendant avec 50 invités
chaque année on le fait John polni c'est
un prix Nobel
en 1998 Jean belivault Paul Anderson
c'est à bonne comme Tom
invités nous avons
donc célébrer la reine Elizabeth avec
les plus illustres esprit du Canada
que la produit dans la première
cinquantaine de ces années au pouvoir
une demie dernière visite chez elle
était à 120 grammes un domaine qui
aimait beaucoup car elle y avait ses
chevaux et le prince le prince Harry
adorait particulièrement on a mangé
ensemble et
elles son regard bleu persan s'est
dirigé vers moi tout d'un coup elle a
dit je ne vais jamais abandonné ça m'a
surpris et j'ai répondu je n'aurais
jamais cru que vous le feriez
et elle a répondu ce n'est pas notre
tradition
mais si je devenais peut-être
complètement gaga on devrait peut-être
faire quelque chose
et la garder le cap jusqu'à la toute fin
concentré
pleine de sens du devoir calme et quoi
Nîmes
tout comme sa mère remarquable et son
père héroïque
sa vie fut guidée par l'intention et
maintenant 20 ans plus tard elle nous a
soudainement quitté
nous nous y attendions pas
nous pensions qu'elle vivrait aussi
longtemps que sa mère plus de 100 ans
elle nous a donné cette remarquable
période de platine qui nous aide à voir
à quel point nous avons changé et
évoluer pendant plus de 70 ans
chacun de nous a des souvenirs
importants tirer de sa propre vie dans
le cadre de ses 70 ans
my house
en tant que gouverneur général était
de donner la sentiment Royal le 13
avril
2000 au traité de niska alors que le
chef m'a observait depuis la
galerie du Sénat on allait donc pavé la
voix à la reconnaissance de toutes les
injustices causées au peuple d'octobre
dans le nouveau siècle c'était une étape
très importante
vers la guérison et la réconciliation en
tant que canadienne je suis si fière que
Marie Simon notre gouverneur général et
inou
la vie et le règne de Elizabeth II
et témoins de nos
efforts en tant que canadien et nos
défis
nous allons devenir ce qu'on devait
devenir la vérité les peuples nordiques
et les peuples libres
[Musique]
quand la nuit
tombe sur nous et sur la terre
et les étoiles
Perse le cœur du ciel
[Musique]
tout celle-là
oui
[Musique]
pendant tout près de 9 ans j'ai eu le
privilège de servir
à titre de Premier ministre canadien de
sa reine comme vous pourriez vous
attendre parfois
j'ai eu l'occasion de mieux comprendre
son rôle de chef d'État et cela de façon
un peu plus formelle on a eu bien des
interactions sur toutes sortes de sujets
et j'aimerais penser que peut-être
peut-être la reine et moi avons établi
une relation au-delà de la relation
entre un chef de gouvernement et un chef
d'État
nous étions alignés sur bien des camps
des enjeux surtout quand il était
question de l'unité canadienne et aussi
le commun Ouest
dans ces années quand le Canada était à
l'avant-plain de la bataille pour la
libération de Nelson mandala et
l'élimination du système cruel qui était
la partie d'un Afrique du Sud il me fait
plaisir de noter que l'ancien Premier
ministre club et parmi nous aujourd'hui
et il était avec les mois pendant ces
années-là
elle se battre pour cet objectif que
Mandela a appelé son plus grand triomphe
mais ce triomphe comme Joe peut le
confirmer n'aurait pas été possible sans
le comme dans le comme Noël était du
rôle joué par Sa Majesté elle a été
vraiment discrète et brillante à la fois
avec un instinct vraiment très très
clair pour la victoire qui était la
nôtre
la bienveillance dans Sa Majesté faisait
preuve envers le Canada et son peuple et
qui allait bien au-delà du simple fait
que l'on était une chef d'État
elle était notre reine bien sûr ainsi
que celle d'autres pays
mais elle est prouvée je pensais un
amour particulier
un nouveau point fort pour le Canada
pour sa diversité sa géographie et son
histoire
elle manifestait sans conteste
un enthousiasme soutenu pour l'avenir et
pour la vigueur du plus grand pays
de son royaume
même pendant sa toute première visite en
1951 elle a noté que dès que j'ai mis le
pied
sur le sol canadien
le sentiment d'étrangeté est disparu car
je savais que j'étais non seulement
parmi les amis mais parmi des
compatriotes
et au président en 1983
qui lui a demandé à mesure qu'elle se
préparait à quitter la Californie pour
la Colombie Britannique après une visite
d'État aux États-Unis le président regen
a demandé où vous partez maintenant
votre Majesté elle a répondu monsieur
le Président je rentre chez moi au
Canada
qu'avez-vous et le renne à l'histoire du
bilinguisme au Canada était même une
fois par
sa maîtrise du français qu'elle parlait
à la perfection
son désir de favoriser
l'épanouissement et la vigueur de la
langue française
son respect inestimable pour le rôle
unique joué par les Canadiens français
dans l'avancement du Québec moderne
et je remarque le pays qui est Canada
maintenant de même que son engagement
profond pour l'unité canadienne qu'elle
voyait
comme un gage d'équité de possibilités
et d'égalité pour tous
comme un qui a eu le privilège
d'entretenir une relation importante
avec Sa Majesté pendant de longues
années j'ai pu vous dire ceci
elle était vraiment très intelligente
une femme de jugement impeccable
déterminé altruiste et avec un
sens la répartie hors pair sans oublier
sa gentillesse les événements de par le
monde nous disent régulièrement qu'il y
a d'un violence qu'il y a des coups
d'état de l'instabilité et il y a des
gens ordinaires dans le chagrin la
détresse à mesure que leur pays sombre
dans la guerre la dévastation et la
ruine
comparer cela au Canada
maintenant à 155 ans un pays fort et
fier
prospère
unis et serein avec des revers et des
défis à relever bien sûr ce n'est pas un
pays parfait nous avons nos problèmes
mais nous sommes en grande mesure bien
peu infectée par l'espace de
mécontentement social et politique qui
ont détruit tant de pays de par ce monde
le succès du Canada
admiré de par le monde comme modèle de
civilité d'équité des qualités et en
fait de réussite ce n'est pas un
accident de l'histoire
le système de notre gouvernement choisi
par nos fondateurs y est pour quelque
chose et c'est peu dire le système
parmental britannique
sous la monarchie aujourd'hui
notre système peut paraître un peu
anachronistique un peu dépassé pour
certains voir sur un nid je le comprends
je l'ai comprends mais selon moi
la très grande majorité des Canadiens
comprennent la monarchie et surtout le
rôle irremplaçable par Sa Majesté
bête II pendant 70 ans était
indispensable dans les réalisations
incroyables de notre pays et les
contributions à la paix et à la
prospérité voir la stabilité chez nous
comme outre-mer
son service brillant et ses
contributions sur cette décennies ont en
fait pour soutenir et élever les
concepts de la liberté et de la
démocratie
qui nous entend honoré et qui nous ont
vraiment fait fleurir
puisse Dieu bénir la reine
et puis Dieu protéger le roi
[Musique]
ceux qui chantent
les vieux parents les vrais amis
ceux qui ont laissé leur
dans un paysage endormi
ce qui s'en vont ceux qui nous laisse
[Musique]
le cœur serré les cheveux gris
ce qui n'ont pas laissé d'adresse
comme s'il voulait qu'on les oublie
ce qui s'en vont ce qui nous est
avec le silence ou la pluie
avec la force ou la faiblesse
de vouloir être encore en vie
vie ce qui s'en vont ce qui nous laisse
en étrange et au paradis
ceux qui emportent leur tendresse
et leur sourire à l'infini
ceux qui chantent vont ceux qui nous le
[Musique]
avec des fleurs au bout des doigts
qui sont partis pour qui pourquoi
ceux qui s'en vont ceux qui nous
la comme des écoliers dans le froid
les s’évader qui disent
[Musique]
les survivants de l'eau de la
ce qui sent bon ce qui nous est
avec le silence ou la pluie
avec la force ou la plus belle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce qui ça dans ce qui nous laisse
en étrange et au paradis
ceux qui emporte le
tendresse et
[Musique]
leur sourire à l'infini
ceux qui s'en vont ceux qui nous
[Musique]
ce qui change
ce qui nous laisse
[Musique]
si plus court de kerfs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
entre tes mains
souverain miséricordieux
soyez
dans la joie et l'espoir et l'amour
pendant le reste de vos jours
qui dépasse tout compris sur
soit avec lui et demeures pour toujours
quand même
[Musique]
je suis
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh
est
à toi la gloire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il s'est porté la croix
ton histoire
es-tu une épopée
des plus brillants exploits
[Musique]
S
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors mon père un petit peu notre signal
donc problème de communication avec
cette cérémonie qui s'achève à l'église
chrysters d'Ottawa cérémonie qui a duré
environ une heure assez émouvante quand
même donc je retrouve mes invités sur le
plateau Marc Estelle et l'ancien
sénateur Serge Joyal donc un petit mot
sur ce que vous retenez de cette
cérémonie
beaucoup de beaucoup d'émotions mais
très contenu et en plus avec une
certaine forme j'ose dire de d'espoir
la reine avec exprimé le souhait que
c'est funérailles ne soient pas triste
et je pense que lorsqu'on a entendu
certaines des artistes performés
on se rendait compte qu'il y avait
beaucoup de beaucoup d'amour beaucoup de
d'affection pour la personne à qui dédié
évidemment leur performance et je crois
que la reine aurait été satisfaite que
la cérémonie était ouverte également au
niveau des religions on ne se sentait
pas en carcané dans une seule fois il y
avait des croyances diverses il y avait
une sorte de d'équilibre également je
pense dans ces croyances tout comme on
peut ne pas avoir de croyances et je
crois qu'on pouvait être très à l'aise
dans cette cérémonie là et ça je crois
qu'il y a un avant-hier il y a une sorte
de réflexion de ce que nous sommes comme
pays finalement
très grande diversité la place du
français était à mon avis tout à fait
juste
on n'était pas relayé à la marge je
crois que la présence du français au
Canada si on écoute cette cérémonie on
se dit les deux langues sont sur un pied
d'égalité en usage et en privilège je
crois que la cérémonie rendait compte de
ce principe là est-ce que j'ai apprécié
beaucoup
[Musique]
la présence des autochtones
imaginez en 53 où nous étions à l'égard
des autochtones nous pensions encore à
polir les réserves et à les assimiler
complètement
regardez où ils étaient aujourd'hui
monsieur Dumont au nom de la nation
quibergy parce que l'Église crasher
s'est construite sur des territoires qui
appartiennent aux Algonquins tout comme
le Parlement d'ailleurs il a rendu un
témoignage à l'histoire en reconnaissant
les torts du passé mais en nous
engageant à les réparer et je reviens
sur des propos de Monsieur Laurendeau
s'il y a eu un passé colonial qui est
absolument indéniable dans le passé nous
sommes ailleurs aujourd'hui et s'il y a
eu des torts de causer dans le passé
c'est à nous à les réparer et c'est à
nous apprendre le devant pour rétablir
cette volonté de vivre en commun de
partager en commun le territoire avec
les menaces qui placent dessus qui
plantent dessus avec évidemment les
changements climatiques qu'on connaît
alors il y avait dans cette dans cette
cérémonie là beaucoup de
contemporanéité de ce que nous sommes
des défis que nous avons mais également
de la confiance que nous avons les uns
dans les autres et je crois que les
propos de Madame Clarkson à cet égard
était très émouvant monsieur meuronnet
également on a connu ces initiatives à
l'égard de la liberté dans le monde le
Canada un rôle à jouer dans le monde et
nous le jouons à travers le commonwear
Sénégal il y a une opportunité que la
couronne nous offre et c'est à nous de
mettre notre intelligence en pratique
pour qu'on utilise ce
lien que nous avons avec la couronne
pour apporter une plus grande mesure de
justice et d'égalité alors la couronne
n'est pas un symbole de domination elle
a été dans le passé mais elle ne lit
plus et d'ailleurs avec le nouveau roi
je m'attends des changements à des
modifications tout comme on en a eu
énormément avec la reine Elisabeth II
alors on verra aussi cette réflexion
maintenant avec la disparition de la
reine nous mènera Estelle vous qu'est-ce
que vous retenez moi j'ai retenu surtout
les champs de
thank you song c'était magnifique et ça
disait bien ce que tout le monde pendant
ces 10 jours on dit merci évidemment le
chant de Ginette Reno ceux qui s'en vont
vous voyez c'est ensuite tout ému la
musique nous touche particulièrement oui
et le champ de
l'allélujah que je refuse
c'était ça aussi c'était très touchant
et même à la même étant là on a vu
fleuri à la fin alors les champs ont
bien fait ressortir ce que
la
variété la multiculaire
aussi représente et pour moi l'échange
c'est ce qui m'ont le plus touché dans
cette cérémonie
mais on réussissait à établir le lien
entre Elisabeth II et les Canadiens la
cérémonie y parvenait parfaitement
d'abord le témoignage de Madame carcine
très très émouvant c'est un témoignage
personnel c'était pas un discours
qu'elle s'était fait écrire c'était
ça venait d'elle de son humour de sa
grande maîtrise du français aussi oui
elle a rencontré Elisabeth alors ces
témoignage j'étais tout à fait ancienne
Hong Kongaise donc qui a vécu elle
rappelait d'ailleurs que les démocraties
se forment lentement elle rappelait
histoire de Charles Ier qui avait été
exécuté Cromwell qui dont la tête a été
hissé sur une pique par la suite
ça peut prendre un bout de temps ça
brasser là dans ce pays de monarchie
c'est pas constitutionnel à l'époque
mais de monarchie alors qu'elle
rappelait
une colonie une colonie qui tombe pas
très bien ces temps-ci mais qu'elle a du
fuir d'ailleurs à l'époque et elle était
bien accueillie ici elle est parvenue au
plus haut de sphère je pense c'est un
témoignage très très émouvant je retiens
aussi celui Ibrahim Rooney
à part le lacmiche et qui a mon avis un
bon héritage je sais pas si vous en
conviendrez même si ça peut réussir un
de ses meilleurs héritages c'est
justement à travers le commonwealt
d'avoir rêvé d'avoir avec la reine avec
la connivence de la reine d'avoir réussi
à
faire quand on boycotte ou syndicat
manuelt les sanctions
c'est de là son capitaux aussi je
retiens de fait que sur le plan la reine
était proche elle s'informait de tout ce
qui se passait au Canada l'anecdote que
racontait rom son fils monsieur Leblanc
Dominique Leblanc Dominique voilà le
fait que la reine s'est informée de ce
que c'était le Shawinigan antique et
déjà monsieur chrétien avec une certaine
hauteur de région était prêt à le
démontrer mais ça prouve que la reine
s'informe du Canada
elle est au courant c'est plus qu'un
patinage le fait public et le savait
alors beaucoup de liens finalement
qu'elle avait vu le Canada est-ce que
l'on peut souhaiter c'est que Charles
III en est autant plusieurs en doutes
mais il y a du rattrapage à faire là
pour avoir autant de lier la discussion
mais je vais aller faire un petit saut à
Ottawa avec Daniel Thibault qui est
toujours devant la cathédrale start à
Ottawa alors Daniel vous avez un invité
avec vous
voilà Céline je suis en compagnie de
Ricardo l'arrivée qui était parmi les
600 personnes invitées à la cérémonie
aujourd'hui
Ricardo dites moi parlez-moi de la
cérémonie qu'est-ce que vous en retenez
ça à l'image de tout ce qu'on a eu
depuis le début des cérémonies que ce
soit à Londres ici c'est sobre les gens
se recueillent ils pensent à la
continuité au travail bien fait ça a été
dit souvent alors j'étais très heureux
de d'assister à cette cérémonie qui
unique dans l'histoire il y avait il y
avait une volonté de la part de la part
des gens de la part des organisateurs de
refléter l'histoire ou la relation entre
la reine Élisabeth et et le Canada ce
que vous avez l'impression qu'on a
ressenti ça dans la semaine oui oui du
début à la fin puis on le sentait on le
sait pas on le sent pas autant au Québec
à quel point la reine était attachée
à la langue française au Québec
moins ici en fait au Québec parce que
elle voulait pas créer de malaise mais
en fait c'était probablement une de ces
provinces favorites dû à la langue et à
la culture et ça je pense que si les
gens lui ont rendu
pour vous d'être ici aujourd'hui le sens
du devoir de promettre quelque chose et
de le faire jusqu'au bout ça nous manque
je trouve souvent que ce soit en
politique ou ailleurs dire je vais
servir l'État dans son cas jusqu'à la
fin elle le fait je trouve c'est un bel
exemple
on manque d'exemple comme ça un cadeau
d'arriver merci beaucoup
voilà Céline donc Ricardo l'arrivée qui
était qui faisait partie des convives
aujourd'hui ils étaient je vous le
disais environ 600 à l'intérieur de
l'église là il se met à pleuvoir de
façon torrentielle c'est comme si Dame
Nature avait décidé de se prêter au jeu
il y a eu une petite brune tout le long
tout le long de la cérémonie maintenant
c'est beaucoup plus c'est beaucoup plus
dru
parmi les gens qui étaient à l'intérieur
de l'église aujourd'hui
oui peut-être effectivement en sortant
en sortant de la cathédrale Chris Church
donc vous avez vu Ricardo l'arrivée mais
évidemment il y avait d'expoliticiens
des politiciens pratiquement tous les
ministres du Conseil des ministres de
Monsieur Trudeau était là le chef de
l'opposition officielle était là Jack
meeting le chef d'une [ __ ] on a vu
brainberonic s'est adressé qui a rendu
hommage à la reine et Diane klaxon Joker
qui était là aussi et des gens qui sont
impliqués dans des organisations au
Canada qui ont été touchées par la reine
la reine Elizabeth par année plusieurs
organisations ici au Canada et donc il y
a des gens qui tenaient à venir lui
rendre à venir lui rendre hommage il y a
eu un écran géant ou quelques centaines
de personnes ont pu suivre la cérémonie
à l'extérieur de l'église ici pendant ce
temps
très bien merci beaucoup de votre
participation à cette émission daniel
Merci
et on arrive déjà à la fin donc
le roi Charles III qui attend de ce roi
il est quand même venu au Canada 19 fois
la reine est venue 22 fois il y a
parcouru le Canada
d'AST and West et du nord au sud si je
puisse utiliser le mot Sud dans le
contexte la frontière avec nos voisins
d'à côté par la dernière fois ça jamais
été enthousiasme à part la dernière non
mais ce que je veux souligner c'est que
c'est un roi qui connaît le Canada quand
je l'ai rencontré en privé à edmunton en
1983 après avec Lady die pour
l'inauguration des jeux du commonwalth
il m'a dit c'est les jeux du commonweath
donc ça doit être en anglais puisque
l'anglais et la langue demande du
commonwald et je lui dis oui votre Votre
Altesse mais nous sommes au Canada et au
Canada il y a deux langues oui mais j
nous sommes en Alberta et l'Alberta
c'est une province hyper majoritairement
anglaise
oui mais le principe d'égalité d'usage
des langues c'est à travers le Canada ou
qu'on soit au Canada et
on a discuté d'où ça venait etc les et
il m'a dit à la fin j'aimerais que vous
reveniez m'expliquer à Londres
à mon bureau
davantage d'informats que vous me
donniez davantage d'informations
pourquoi cette loi était adoptée en 69
la Loi sur les langues officielles alors
quand je vois le roi Charles de toit et
j'entends les commentaires comment
va-t-il être ce qu'on voit l'aimer
autant est-ce qu'il y aura la même type
de relation
affectueuse que la majorité des gens
aient prouvé à l'égard de la reine moi
je me dis parce qu'il ne le connaissent
pas comme vous dites très bien
on prend pour acquis que c'était la
reine et que lui était en second mais je
crois que comme on dit la fonction fait
la personne alors on verra parce qu'on
va voir malheureusement ça se termine
Boutier dire un petit mot mais on verra
oui on va il faut donner une chance au
coureur c'est certain c'est ça c'est moi
je suis convaincu que leur voix Charles
va être capable de laisser sa marque il
faut lui donner le temps
déjà il a commencé à poser des gestes
extrêmement positifs et
laissant lui le temps il a eu 70 ans
pour se préparer maintenant c'est celui
qui a eu le plus de temps pour se
préparer quelques secondes
un certain état de grâce mais il y a
certaines critiques qui ont été faites
vis-à-vis ces gestes des patients
évidemment c'est un bémol la tout ça
parce qu'il a été admirable dans les
bains de foule quand il s'est adressé à
la population on le voyait la caméra
merci d'avoir été là voilà pour cette
émission spéciale merci de nous avoir
suivis depuis tôt ce matin au revoir on
se laisse sur des images de ce qui s'est
passé
[Musique]